so Donald Trump Kid Rock Tucker Carlson
Dana White all come out at UFC at
Madison Square Garden and the whole
Arena erupts in cheering this is massive
Democrats know Joe Biden can't win his
polls are in the gutter Trump is winning
in Aggregate and when Donald Trump has
New York City cheering for him and
Tucker Carlson and Kid Rock it uh
doesn't paint a very good picture for uh
the Democrats however Gavin Newsome is
probably going to be their Ace in the
Hole and at some point he's going to
announce he's taking over V ramaswami
masterfully calling them out saying we
know he's running a shadow campaign we
know Biden's not going to be the guy so
we got news out of California gav Nome
is admitting that they only cleaned up
the homeless problem because xiin ping
was coming and uh this is a big Scandal
and then we'll talk about we've got this
uh there's another podcast you may have
heard of h3h3 and leftover and Hassan
they do a show called leftovers
that apparently is in Jeopardy and this
is a pretty popular uh leftwing show
it's in Jeopardy because Ethan Klein is
married to an IDF veteran he is Jewish
and Hassan is absolutely Pro
Palestine and it's resulted in some very
tumultuous circumstances where on some
of their live shows you've got 30 plus
thousand people in the chat just
spamming free Palestine and from The
River To The Sea and things like this
and it's leading to some very serious
tension that I think uh exemplifies very
much so the the implosion that we are
seeing here in the culture War even
people on the right from pro-israel to
Pro Palestine and on the left it's
creating very interesting Dynamics so
we're going to talk about all of that my
friends but before we do head over to
timcast.net we launched documentary last
week with Lauren Southern it's an
amazing view of gun rights in the United
States and if you're a fan you should
definitely check it out become a member
to support the work we're doing because
if you like gun rights and you like the
documentary support us by becoming a
member so we can make more of these
things but more importantly share it
with your friends and family members if
they're not super familiar about how
these things work and to give it a
general idea of gun culture from people
who know about guns too many of the
people in this country are trying to
pass laws don't know a dang thing about
it by becoming a member clicking join us
you'll get access to the documentary as
well as our members only uncensored show
which will be coming up just after the
main portion of the live show at 10 p.m.
and you'll get access to our Discord
server where you can actually send in
questions and talk to us in the
uncensored portion talk to us and our
guests so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole lot more is
Aaron mat good to be here uh who are you
what do you do I'm a journalist I write
uh articles and with the greyzone the
grey zone.com I also write for some
other outlets too and uh yeah I've been
in independent journalism for a long
time and you get kicked off trains I got
kicked off a train today on my way here
yeah but I you you were confronting a
senator yes yes Senator Chris Coons was
sitting right across from me and I had
to take the opportunity to ask him about
his stance on Gaza he opposes a
ceasefire so I asked him about it he
didn't take kindly to it and um yeah he
just said we're in the quiet car stop st
talking to me he's right we were in the
quiet car so I did violate the quiet car
rules although I did speak I did speak
in Qui voice and after you know about 2
minutes he got up and left and then came
back and had me move and I did move and
eventually he walked by me again and saw
me I think that triggered him and next
thing I knew the next stop I was asked
to leave the train wow so even after you
said okay and you left the car and went
somewhere else he came and got you
kicked off again correct cuz the mrack
attendant said unless you move you're
going to be removed so I I complied wow
and then I went and sat in the same car
in the same car and he happened to walk
by saw me I looked at him we didn't I
didn't say anything though cuz I'm
respecting the the new rules I was uh
that were imposed on me and I think that
triggered him and so I was gone right on
well this should be interesting so
thanks for hanging out we have a lot to
talk about we got Libby hanging out hey
how's it going glad to be here I'm Libby
Emmons I'm the editor-in chief with the
post-millennial and human events.com I'm
Ian crosslin dude Aaron it sounds like
the the vibration of your presence was
making noise in his head I think it was
like that was his conscience it was it
was feedback is it mate or mate how do
you mate mate you got both wrong I like
it fine say how you want thanks man is
there an accent over one of the E on the
end cool man good to see you well hey
I'm Ian crossin uh my interviews have
been wild this last week I interviewed
Jimmy corsetti on Friday we talked about
Atlantis and I'm still fired up about it
so if you haven't seen him check them
out after this show I'll remind
everybody again let's rock and roll and
uh I'm surge.com and I'm ready to start
when you at Tim this is the big story it
actually is pretty interesting Donald
Trump greeted by cheers upon arrival at
UFC 295 in New York City it was wasn't
just Donald Trump it was Tucker Carlson
and Kid Rock and I must stress this for
you all again in New York City probably
what is this the deepest blue blue can
be in this country I well no that's not
fair I mean I guess Portland maybe well
and they did flip a City Council seat
last week a City Council seat in the
Bronx w Wait a republican
yeah and there was a there was another
flip I think in Long Island wow this is
getting CRA New Yorkers are getting
pissed they're tired of all this garbage
I think seeing Donald Trump get massive
cheers in New York City should be as
soon as I see this I'm like all the
polls that are claiming Trump's within a
point or two above Joe Biden they're
wrong he's got to be higher than that
you you you look I know we can all say
that UFC fighters are based and so the
fans are probably more you know right
leaning whatever I don't believe that
the people I know who are watching
fights they're just regular people UFC
is a mainstream popular sport and Donald
Trump shows up in New York City to Mad
Square Garden and the and the Crowd Goes
Nuts I think it's fair to say Joe Biden
can't win but I also think everyone
listening to this show already knows
it's not going to be Joe Biden anyway
right well and these are probably a lot
of people from New Jersey also you know
there's like New Jersey and New York in
the crowd yeah but it's all blue it's
all it's awesome yeah I think it's great
did you see Bill bur's wife was flipping
off oh that was great too yeah she
flipped off Trump she flipped off Trump
from from behind see it's it's New York
it's not all uh all love for Trump I
guess people Express but so so so so
what's our what's our prescription here
or what's our what's our prediction is
probably the better way to put it it's
it's Donald Trump in New York City
getting thunderous Applause with Tucker
Tucker Carlson okay just right there I
mean Tucker Carlson's walking through
medic Square guard everyone's screaming
and cheering okay it's not a good sign
for for Joe Biden in 2024 and the rest
of the Democrats I think in uh what was
it in Kentucky the last election last
week the only thing Democrats won was
the the governor's race and it was super
close and it was an incumbent so I mean
right coming advantage and then the rest
of the all these other positions ended
up going to Republicans so it is looking
like at least right now based on what we
saw last week and what I mean a lot of
people are saying it was really bad for
Republicans but I think what we're
seeing right now in New York City you
mentioned them flipping a seat I don't I
don't see how Democrats can win unless
they radically shift their strategy
right now what about all of the wins
that we saw last week like in Ohio they
had a sweeping abortion law that was
like a constitutional amendment and then
um a number of other places those are
wins for Democrats yeah we saw a lot of
democrat wins last week they legalized
weed in Ohio they legalized weed in Ohio
yeah I don't I think that's that's a
mistake Republicans are making I who who
was who was talking about this I I know
maybe Mike cernovich was tweeting about
it abortion is generally popular in the
United States to the point where people
don't actually care the full extent of
what's being legalized the pro-life
position is not going to win out yeah
it's something that if you want to
actually make a pro-life change you've
got to somehow get the population to
follow you for other reasons and then
kind kind of subconsciously get them to
to become pro-life but screaming it is
not going to make people this is why I
think it's important to like if you're
pro-life it makes more sense to Advocate
against abortion than to advocate for
abortion to be
illegal yeah like they're not the same
thing abortion can be legal and you can
encourage people not to do it right
making showing the morality of it I
think watching the baby get dismembered
in the womb as it's being pulled out or
just offering more options for moms like
you can be a mom it's okay you know yeah
I was talking to a friend of mine and he
was mentioning how he he he he bought
something he he well I don't want to
give out too many details cuz some you
know this other dude's private life but
he was trying to help a local kid with
some extracurricular activities and his
family was not very well off so he said
let me help you out and you know buy you
some some stuff to help your kids and
when he said this a bunch of people
started calling him a creepo and a pedo
for trying to for helping this little
girl with like her school stuff and he
was like man I felt so bad I was like
what did I do something wrong like why
are people yelling at me like post it
online like hey I just you you know was
buying the stuff for this family and
they tacked him for it and I'm like it
is really funny that what there there's
a cultural narrative for guys like we
have all these stories where a guy sting
on an airplane and then it's like he'll
be sitting next to a kid and the flight
tent comes up and says you have to move
because you're a man sitting next to a
child and then we've had these for years
and then for women you have these
stories where it's like oh don't have a
family it's bad for the environment or
you're not going to have fun or you're
going to Rd it it's like man they really
don't want people having kids no they
don't and they don't want people around
kids they just want to get rid of kids
entirely yeah right yeah I guess but at
any rate I don't know where are we at I
got a prediction on this Gavin Newsome
comes in with on a chariot of fire and
everyone's like why is this guy but then
the media pushes him so hard for a year
and they're like Trump bad Newsome good
and you get a bunch of people behind it
and then unless we have election
integrity and the votes are on machines
behind the scenes I have no way to
verify whether or not the votes are
going to get hacked and flip 5149 but I
don't trust the process if it's done
secretly on proprietary machines these
days I just don't I I gotta be honest I
don't know where we're at in terms of
like I I have a general idea Joe Biden
can't win as of right now but there's
got to be some kind of insane and
dramatic change that happens over the
next several months in order for there
to be a viable race for Democrats in
2024 but look at Joe Biden's entire
career he's a Serial liar in the 80s
when he was running for president he was
caught plagiarizing the speech of a
British politician his whole life story
he's the meant that he thought he was
fighting apar in South Africa he thought
he was fighting for civil rights in the
US so he's out of touch and I think
accordingly he's going to be out of
touch enough to believe he has a chance
and I think he'll stay in the race yeah
but they got to remove him right I mean
so there's a couple views one is that
the Deep State whatever you want to call
it is like why won't Joe Biden stop we
need someone else we can't win and so
now you're seeing all the hunter Biden
stuff Bubble Up and the threat of
impeachment and conviction if Joe Biden
doesn't leave people people think
they're going to take they're going to
remove him by force from office in a
speech I think was it today he said
president Harris well he said that like
8 times I know but he says it a bunch I
think that I think he's really just
trying to get us used to it and they'd
have to remove her too because obviously
they can't run her as well because she's
so unpopular probably less popular than
he is so yeah no uh the impeachment
could actually have some legs if uh
people inside his own party get behind
it because but the problem is the
impeachment has to do with Ukraine and
they they're sensitive about that
because they're so embedded in Ukraine
and they don't want to admit defeat
there and the Ukraine impeachment gets
to Joe Biden's corruption there and his
big role in causing this whole mess well
this is why I'm saying I don't know
where we're at because that's a really
great point if they move to him if Joe
Biden won't leave and they know he's
going to lose okay hold on slow down if
Donald Trump wins all their War plans
are going to get screwed up it's it's
not like you know Trump's going to just
end everything overnight but it's
certain he's not not going to give them
what they want so they can't have Donald
Trump but he's the front runner for the
Republicans and he's going to do really
well well so then they have Joe Biden
okay well if Joe Biden stays in the race
he's going to lose and they're going to
get Trump can't have that but if they
try to remove Joe Biden using
impeachment you're right it's Ukraine
and now whoopsy Daisy how many other
people are are going to get caught up in
whatever that disaster is they do have
them though on the classified documents
case there is an investigation into that
which we which we forgot about because
it gets buried but they could pull that
out if they really wanted something to
get him on they could use that and if
they do then they come back and say oh
look we're being fair Trump you can't be
president either I think if they go
after every time I see them um talking
about the Biden classified documents I
think this is just a way to get Trump
because they don't care what happens to
Biden and they want Trump out of the
way well if you're someone inside the
establishment and you hate both Biden
and Trump uh for your own reasons then
this classified documents thing it's
like you kill two birds with one stone
because you pretend like you're applying
the law equally yep you claim you're
upholding Justice and you get them both
so if I'm making a prediction I think
they're going to go with that if they
really Nome versus Des
santis aren't they debating soon aren't
they having that happen that's the plan
yeah the thing is I don't think you can
stop Trump he's just shown to be so
resilient he freestyled his entire 2016
campaign right inevitable yeah he's you
know he has inevitable he if you look at
him physically he has a terrible diet
but he's just seems indestructible he's
77 years old so the only person who can
really stop out there playing golf
anyway there you go yeah you going say
the only person that could stop Trump
only person stop Trump is Trump himself
somehow he hangs it up personally but
otherwise I just don't think all these
cases against him like what is he facing
700 years yeah but you look at them and
you go I mean maybe on the classified
documents one there's something I don't
know I I don't know that one too closely
but the other ones like the racketeering
case in Georgia it seems everyone who's
not a hardcore partisan Democrat
understands what's going on there I
think with the docs I don't think that
they get him on the documents because
you have judge canon in Florida who has
now pushed the court date back and she
said you know we're not going to do this
on an accelerated schedule so that's
just going to drag on for a while I
think he I think they have a better shot
of getting him on the January 6th case
because they've got a gag order slapped
on them already right um and they're
really going to go hard after him on
that one they have a judge who has
already with other January 6 cases uh
advocated for or issued sentences that
are longer even than the justice
department had asked for I think that's
where they're I think they're going to
get him in that one and I think they I
think they've a shot at getting major
I don't how would you describe yourself
politically if you would Aaron
traditionally leftwing so and the and
the meaning of that has changed in
recent years because now to be leftwing
you have to side with neocons to support
proxy wars like in Ukraine but which is
weird full circle they say yeah exactly
so I'd say traditionally leftwing so
that's why I think it's interesting
because uh you know based on your
political views where you are are are
are people calling you right-wing have
they been calling you rightwing for some
time yeah ever since I started opposing
russan gate which I thought was the
dumbest thing of all time uh and it
speaks to this issue we're talking about
this desperate effort to get Trump and
also undermine any diplomacy between the
US and Russia by calling him a Russian
asset and all the conspiracy theories
that came with that ever since I started
questioning that was called right-wing I
was called an apologist for Trump even
though as a side even like putting us
even if I didn't care about facts and
being a journalist which is what when
you're a journalist you're supposed to
follow the facts no matter where they
lead uh for for partisan purposes
putting that aside from a political
point of view I was also against it cuz
I thought it was a big gift to Trump cuz
what's a bigger gift to Trump than
trying to oppose him from the sole point
of view and this really was the
obsession of him being a Russian asset
like putting all your eggs into the
basket of a crazy conspiracy theory I
thought it was a big gift to him and and
the Republicans and so because I was
opposed to that I was accused of uh of
supporting Trump and then you were
critical of uh war in Ukraine and then I
was of course I was because one of the
reasons why I hated Russia gate was
because it also promoted this neocon
narrative that we should not have
diplomacy with Russia that Russia's
responsible for all of our problems and
it's a good thing to fight the war in
Ukraine rather than resolve it with the
Peace Accords that were on the table
that's what Trump's first impeachment
was about people forget this he was
impeached for briefly pausing some
weapons to Ukraine while allegedly
pressuring Ukraine to investigate the
bidens and by the way the case was the
case if you looked at it never had any
actual evidence Trump did make some dumb
comments in a phone call to zalinski but
the fundamental charge against Trump
that he was like leveraging us weapons
to Blackmail zinsky there was actually
never there was never actually any
evidence for it what it did do was
promote this cold war narrative that we
should be fighting this war with Russia
Adam Schiff on the house floor when he
was leading the impeachment said that we
Aid Ukraine so that we can fight Russia
over there we don't have to fight Russia
here and I remember thinking is this
what being a left Winger is now we have
to support uh fighting a proxy war with
Russia and look where it got us it got
us into this allout hot War over the
last few years so one of M reasons why
why I thought Russia gate was a huge
scam and a big danger and it's it's
weird how all of these like I don't know
how to describe it these weird
authoritarian things align with what is
described as the left today and if you
are somebody who holds left economic
views but criticizes the war machine or
like Adam schiff's statements and and
how they've gone after Trump you are now
right-wing you are far right they'll
call you far right for simply being like
well Trump didn't do that ah we got you
yeah they'll call you Russian asset and
they will look the other way or cheer on
people being censored in the name of
cracking down on so-called
disinformation so look at for example
the reporting on the hunter Biden laptop
before the election they rolled out the
Russia gate Playbook because some
embarrassing emails from Hunter Biden's
laptop emerged and rather than let
people look at the contents of the
laptop and make up their own minds they
censored it in the name of fighting
Russia which was of course another
complete scam so that entrenched that
Playbook but I don't think it's
inclusive to the left now in the because
of this conflict in Gaza you're seeing
plenty of Republican politicians calling
for censoring voices that support
Palestinian rights you're seeing people
called anti-semites unfairly you're
seeing College groups being shut down
like at Columbia two two groups just got
shut down for their Palestinian advocacy
so I do think on both sides you have
this um certainly during the Russia gate
era it was it it was happening a lot on
the liberal side and people like me were
the target of it this is a crazy thing
the uh the the the Israel Palestine
issue
has ripped both the left and the right
in half in this really weird way it's
pretty wild and I I think it's I I I I
don't necessarily know how this position
starts but there are these funny comics
uh Stone toss is a comic where it's like
a communist with like a a guilded age
oligarch and they're both pulling the
rope together and there's a Libertarian
and a fascist pulling the rope together
like what is what is this like what is
this political debate that we're having
and so what you end up with is uh
somehow several years ago people who
were right leaning or conservative in
their values were moving towards pro-
Free Speech people who were disaffected
liberals or former Democrats are now
agreeing with Trump supporters Trump was
moderate even Steve Bannon says he's a
moderate in our movement no no no
vox.com called Trump a moderate back in
2015 and and so these like you look at
Trump's bum stck ban he is not this
farri you know anarchist or libertarian
or anything like these things so what's
interesting is that as long as Israel
wasn't in the debate so protective Edge
happens 2014 and then after that you get
this period where there are people who
are very critical of Israel and people
who are very supportive is of Israel but
as long as they're not talking about it
they're all working together and the
same is true for pro Gaza or or critical
of of Hamas or Pro palestin should
saying critical of Hamas you've got now
uh uh Hassan perer and Ethan Klein in
this fight over this let let me let me
pull this one up and we'll actually talk
about it because this exemplifies things
very very well we have this clip it was
posted on Twitter it's got half a
million views lofty pixel says Ethan
breaks down on stream after withstanding
an unending barrage of 30,000 cultists
in Hassan's chat spamming Hamas are
resistance Fighters and from The River
To The Sea and Zionist Pig perpetually
for three straight hours let me uh let
me play this clip for you guys sounds
just like their Discord actually man and
you know I'm not a radical Jew
I'm not even a religious Jew I have no
I have no stake in the game and
this is coming
from yeah it's still playing I know I
know Ethan uh is now he just gets up and
leaves so then we have another clip
there's there's a bunch of things that
have been posted this is uh the
quartering posted this four hours ago
Ethan Klein has Klein has epic meltdown
after Hassan calls him stupid to his
face we'll play this uh briefly saying
black lives matter doesn't insinuate the
other lives don't matter it's it's in
the pH bro I don't know what to tell you
from the from the river to the Sea
Palestine will be free also doesn't
feature from The River To The Sea we
should destroy Israel and kill all the
Jews you're the one who's saying that
that is the secondary implication behind
it well I I I think that and then uh of
course we have this clip this is from
too lazy to try where he posts this clip
we actually I couldn't find this one I
don't know where he got this clip from
but it's Ethan Klein basically breaking
this down I'll play a little bit of this
so you can hear what he has to say
Discord and what I saw in that Discord
was Universal near Universal praise for
Hamas near Universal saying people
deserved it people near universally
calling me a Zionist Pig Mass murdering
genocidal
freak and if you want to know the truth
that me up seeing that
Discord because it made me realize
that a lot of these people are watching
this show and it frankly Disturbed me
listen everyone in my periphery everyone
in my circle all the leftist uh people
that I watch that I'm part of that watch
this show because I consider myself part
of that side are all pretty much
uncritically accepting of Hamas
propaganda and un caring about the Revis
rewriting of History right before aing
ey about this stuff so I'm not seeing a
lot of people even though you might look
at the popular media and say you know
everybody supporting Israel this is this
is the this is the breakdown in in pop
culture in modern culture so Ethan Klein
for those that are familiar he's got
h3h3 they they've been big for a really
really long time he's got millions of
subscribers he has a big show Hassan
perer of course is the most prominent
leftist streamer they do a show together
called leftovers and now they're they're
feuding with each other over this one we
we saw Amy Schumer posting articles from
campus reform which is a conservative
leaning publication we are seeing
mainstream celebrities being fired from
their jobs for supporting Israel it is
the weirdest thing to see someone like
you know what I I just got to say this
Ethan
kleene is married to a this this correct
Serge an IDF veteran she everyone in
Israel has to serve with the IDE her
name is El yeah yeah and uh uh so
obviously he's he has connections to
Israel when he started working with
these other leftists I'm just look man I
I how do you not know the views of the
people you're working with this is not
new the leftist protests going back as
far as I know we in support of palestin
we're very critical of Israel I feel
like too many of these celebrities just
said I'll do whatever is popular and now
it's blowing up in their faces because
they ended up saying wait wait wait hold
on I can't support that not to mention
it's this really weird circumstance
where you do have massive massive
popular support for for Palestine
critical of Israel but you have major
corporations that aren't having none of
it a lot of these celebrities are
concerned they're going to lose money
they're going to lose jobs they're going
to get fired if they're critical of
Israel but at the same time if you're
supporting Israel you're getting fired
too so it's like double cancel culture
going on who's gotten fired for
supporting T strong tar she's a voice
actress she got fired without
notification because she was posting a
bunch of stuff on on Twitter like I
stand with Israel people were kidnapped
and whatas is doing and then they
abruptly post saying we'll no longer be
working with her on this show and she's
like one of the most famous voice
actresses excuse okay in the world I
haven't heard of that my whole life I've
seen people getting cancelled and
smeared and fired for criticizing Israel
so I mean no one should be fired for
their political views I still think
though the overwhelming trend is towards
targeting people for being critical of
Israel I I I do agree and I think that's
why a lot of these celebrities are just
like uh oh this is why you're seeing a
lot of people on the left calling out
black lives matter now because these
leftist institutions these or these
activist organizations that are critical
of Israel Pro Palestine are unabashedly
coming out and saying like nah we're
we're we're in support of this and then
it comes to an extreme degree where you
have uh BLM Chicago posted the
paraglider you had act um several
rallies in New York where the the
activists were actually cheering for
Hamas explicitly and I'm not saying
Palestine they were saying things like
those hipsters you know got kidnapped
and taken I'm sure they're doing fine
things like that people are losing their
jobs for that for sure and now you
you've got those uh uh those uh what was
it the uh wall was it Wall Street
investors putting up a list of the
people they will not hire right they
were saying that there's certain
universities they won't hire from you
have James Lindsay going out there
saying don't hire college graduates
which is fascinating I mean he's saying
that for all of his very specific James
Lindsay reasons not just not like the
Israel thing but um yeah you're seeing a
lot of that the thing in New York um and
the thing with celebrities the thing
with celebrities I I think that a lot of
it they were fine to
criticize um Israel and support
Palestinians because they simply didn't
have they simply didn't believe that an
attack like this would happen and so I
think this was like a visceral reaction
to this attack which is what like the
worst one since since the Holocaust
apparently it's like worse than the yam
kapor War ums there yeah go ahead when
people say it's worse than the Holocaust
I'm like okay well it's not worse than
it's like the biggest yeah that's what
they I'm like okay okay but there's a
dramatic difference 1400 6 million yeah
and and so you know look the issue here
is the only thing that I care about is
the zealotry is like you had uh one
individual who I won't name calling for
well not I I would okay I'll put it this
way she said the only reason not to Nuke
Gaza is because the Fallout would affect
Israelis and I'm like that's insane and
then you also have people like BLM
Chicago posting the the the paraglider
and I'm like y'all people chill with
well the rest what's interesting about
the BLM Chicago thing is that was BLM
Grassroots and BLM National was very
quick to distance themselves from that
group of course they wouldn't have been
last patri Patrice cullers has that
famous line in 2015 where she said we
end what what did you call it end the I
don't remember but I remember see end
the project or whatever that called
Israel or or something she called it
yeah but in in New York when you see
activists pulling down American flags
and putting up Palestinian flags and
stuff that's not um that's not a new
sentiment in New York that's a long I
mean I lived in Bay Ridge in Bay Ridge
Brooklyn for a long time which is very
Arab neighborhood uh you know I was
often like the only the only white
person basically at the grocery store um
and that neighborhood had Pro
Palestinian marches and stuff every
couple of weeks every month or so you
would walk outside and see these big
gatherings of people opposing um
essentially opposing Israel and being
pro Palestinian and that's in a
neighborhood that's very Arab but it's
also like got a lot of Jews in that
neighborhood so I don't think I wasn't
that surprised to see that um erupt in I
was surprised at how many people there
were but that is a long-standing
sentiment coming out of Brooklyn for
sure you know putting aside the content
of pro Palestinian
uh expression a lot of which I would
totally defend I still think there's a
huge power disparity we're talking about
what some activists say or what some
sign say when it comes to the media when
it comes to Congress Rashida Talib just
got censured for uh endorsing the slogan
from The River To The Sea Palestine will
be free which I think is a call for
equality we could debate that if you
want but regardless meanwhile you have
people on the other side Brian masted uh
a member of Congress he's a republican
he said that there's no distinction
between civilians and inside Gaza
Lindsey Graham said we should level the
place referring to Gaza you so you have
Lindsey Graham called for bombing Iran
I'm
likey so so you have people calling for
you know mass murder inside Gaza and
openly endorsing State terrorism saying
there's no distinction between civilians
and Hamas they don't get censured
Rashida T the one palestino American
member of Congress does that's the power
and balance that I think speaks to
what's going on here what does that mean
that she was censured what happened
exactly it's it's a formal resolution
you censure someone you're basically
reprimanding them for speaking out of if
they do it again they get fired or
something well it it entirely depends on
the speaker it depends on uh party
leadership there's like a warning it's
like an official warning or something
it's like a it's a demerit it's like we
hear be SM your honor haha and they sign
but they don't lose anything they just
it's just like yeah losing would have to
come from uh an official action by you
like the speaker or or party a party Me
official so censure is is mostly just
like we hereby declare that you have
done a bad thing yes we have agreed you
have done right wrong however there is
uh when margorie Taylor green got
stripped from all her committees and she
got booted so power disparity really
just spend depends on the subject matter
so I know you're specifically referring
to the Israel Palestine and and not
necessarily any other subject matters I
think the issue with this is I got to be
honest man you know these are the rules
that uh Rashid T wants to live by I have
absolutely no problem with her being
censured first of all it doesn't really
do anything she may it may be bad for
her in the long run because clearly
other members of Congress don't like her
if they're willing to censure her but my
attitude when it comes to free speech
has changed a bit from I think it was
very naive 10 years ago to say something
like we must defend the Free Speech even
for those who disagree with us to where
I'm now at I'll defend the free speech
for anybody who defends Free Speech
anybody who opposes Free Speech will get
no defense from me so if Rashid T and
the people she works with are fine with
censorship of other people I will not be
rushing to her defense okay you know
that's a fair point because you want
moral consistency but I'll defend
anyone's free speech so as someone who
does support that I think it's fair to
oppose her being censored especially if
we're trying to be consistent people
saying it's not moral consistency it is
it is if we allow people who oppose free
speech to like if if there are two
forces and one side says I will give you
leeway and the other side says I will
not give you leeway then over a long
enough period of time the the the the
compromising party will lose and this is
actually the argument made by the left
they show that Carl ER meme all the time
about tolerating intolerance I think
that's a little dry but if I simplify
it's if Rashid T says we must defend
Free Speech defended free speech on
campus denounced the violent riots and
and the attacks on on people for various
opinions I I'd be right now saying like
we must defend ridita T because we
disagree so for instance like Cassandra
candra McDonald who's a good friend of
mine very critical of Israel and she's
adamantly Pro free speech and so I'm
just like I will absolutely defend oh I
got it but how do you know that Rashid
TBA is not pro free speech spe I know of
her also defending the rights of Julian
Assange that to me is a free speech so I
haven't seen any evidence that she's
anti- free speech except for that that
that she's a Democrat which I understand
it's fair enough in these in the in
these times to assume if someone's like
a congressional Democrat they might have
some anti-free speech views I think
that's a fair assumption but in the case
of rash T I can't think of any evidence
offand that she's anti-free speech I
mean have you what have you seen from
her just going back of the past several
years relating to various actions that
have taken place in and around Congress
and various stances and defenses from
Congress pertaining to people like
margerie Taylor green versus illan Omar
it is free speech when it's something I
care about and I if I don't care I'm not
involved right okay but but to be fair
it would be prudent of me to before
saying something like that have like a
list of examples but my point isn't
necessarily to single out Rashida T over
this because I don't think she's like a
a un she's like the epitome of a guilty
party when it comes to not being in
suppor of free speech I agree with him
the Julian Assange stuff and uh uh
Richard T has had some several victories
in the past things that I agree with her
on as well I I'm I'm just more
so censorship is not that big of a deal
but I agree with you on the on the power
disparity for sure when it comes to
Israel and mostly because the
military-industrial complex and the
lobbyists in this country absolutely
want yeah conflict War contracts Etc
Lindsey Graham exemplifies it better
than anything else when he says we
should bomb Iran with or without
evidence what's going on in Israel I
don't think you know we we were asking
uh uh I forgot we asked on the show
about it do you think it's religious
because there are some people who are
deeply religious and they've there's
podcasts that have come out where they
say things like this could be the second
or depending on your on your religion
the first coming of the Messiah and so
and I know it sounds crazy and there's a
lot of people who don't believe this
stuff but there are very serious
prominent Christians and Jews who
believe this may be the Messianic era
the red heer Etc I get so pissed about
that cuz for the Israelis to claim it's
a Jewish thing is putting all the Jewish
people's lives at risk across the Earth
an Israeli thing but my point was we
asked you know is it religion no no no
at the highest levels it's mostly just
military expansion oil energy Etc the US
has desperately wanted to go to war with
Iran having military assets and control
in Israel is massively massively
beneficial to the US military interests
in the region we it was very difficult
to invade Iraq it was very difficult to
to invade Afghanistan we struggled and
failed in both these countries but in
Israel the United States has a very
powerful military foothold not the same
as I'm not saying they have massive
military bases the same as you know like
Afghanistan I mean like they don't need
it when we sending weapons and missiles
and funding and things like that I
totally agree that the US interest is
geopolitical and Israel's been a client
state of the us since 1967 when it
showed that it could smash Arab
nationalism and after that Israel became
very favored by the US bipartisan
establishment now though you do have
this phenomenon of these extremist or of
these um you know uh Evangelical
Christians who are a major base of
support for Israel that is important
especially in some Congressional races
and you also have a pro-israel Lobby too
APAC which also can influence
Congressional races with their sway but
the interest has always been the same
it's just because also Israel has gone
so much to the right and has become the
face of it has become so clear a lot of
its former supporters have turned away
from it because it's it's not as easy as
it used to be I mean I'm I'm Jewish I
grew up in the Jewish Community it used
to be hard for people like me to hold
the view which are critical of Israel
now in my circles nobody nobody defends
Israel anymore so hence they've had to
find other bases of support which is in
the is in the Evangelical Christian
Community I I find with like the left
and the right spreading out but also now
shattering and like kind of almost like
you see this what's happening is if
think of the left and the right on a
globe and it's all around the equator
but it's twisting up like when tensions
get high people become authoritarian
that's going up and then libertarian
will be going down so you go far to the
left but you're also twisting up
becoming more an authoritarian leftist
which is like fight do the thing the
river to the sea or you're going to the
right and getting twisted up into an
authoritarian
rtist smash them all the the nuclear
weapons in Gaza and like or you see the
people's True Colors come out in times
of tension if they become more
libertarian like I'm we should not be
committing more arms to this to escalate
it again and then there's some people
that you know you see the whole globe
and they're like well we're in a
military we're basically controlling
Earth's military right now and Israel's
a big part of that if we let it go
that's going to be a big loss to the
American Military industri let let me
tell you what's really fascinating to me
is uh Ronda santis he orders the
dissolution of these student groups that
state in their like documents or
whatever that they are not in support of
the movement they are the movement Ron
says that's that said they're asserting
that they're Hamas that they are not
just activists and some of these many of
these people involved did they say we
support the Hamas movement or just the
resistance movement in general they said
the the the the documents I want to be
careful because it did not say
explicitly we are Hamas it said the
people who engaged in these fights are
Freedom Fighters and we are part of that
movement as Palestinians in Exile right
okay so so they're saying that they
support resistance but I
mean bis for Palestine I I it was
whatever Ron banned okay Ron's argument
was if you are claiming to be a part of
this movement this group then you can't
be a student group because that violates
the law okay you you can't be actively
trying to support a terrorist
organization you're gone what was
interesting is VI ramaswami came out and
said no way these are students engaged
in free speech actually uh uh talked to
him V gra briefly and I was like yeah
but did you read it they said they're
not suppor of the movement they are the
movement and he said students saying
stupid things is not the same thing as
supplying terrorist organizations are
providing material support Ron should
not be shutting these people down and
then actually on the debate stage said
the same thing I have tremendous respect
for that because VI was not just easily
swayed by this argument many people on
the right who were in support of Israel
were saying like oh yeah but look they
say they are you know they're
effectively saying they are Hamas cuz
that's actually my first instinct was
don't ban the group oh wait they're
saying they Hamas okay well now it's
getting interesting then V pushes back
and says no way free speech so I think
it's interesting uh I think it's it's
it's Troublesome that we are definitely
seeing there are many people who are
pro-israel that would be on the right
that are not for free speech and I think
we have to be careful of I certainly
think it's more so on the left than the
right but opportunists who would claim
to be for free speech and then at a
moment's notice try and ban the speech
of someone they become authoritarian man
and you see it in the In the Heat of the
Moment I don't want to put you know I
really don't want to put Shapiro on
blast Ben I love you return my phone
calls then I'll stop putting you on
blast um no I haven't actually called
him yet but like it shocked me how how
quickly he was screaming about
annihilating a bunch of humans after his
and I fear can do that to somebody you
know and if he was when you're the
military commander you don't have time
to do you mean by that he came out
pretty early on I don't want to put
words in his mouth but he was very much
like we need a swift strong counter
offensive and we need to put this to bed
basically saying Ben's been pretty
adamant that uh uh the killing of
civilians is a tragedy the difference
between him and and the typical left is
that he's in support of uh Israel's
military actions which is resulting in a
lot of Civilian dead his argument and I
I don't I don't mean to argue for him he
can speak for himself but his argument
is more so that there's a difference
between Hamas flying over and targeting
people at a music festival and Israel
targeting military leaders and killing
civilians in the process however he has
also said the killing of any civilian is
a tragedy uh the daily Jeremy boring
also said the death of any Palestinian
civilian woman or child as well as
Israeli are are are tragedies in an
equal sense so I'm not trying to defend
what Ben is saying I'm trying to clarify
his position he's not saying just go
around kill the way he came out and said
it I guess it was the day of or the day
after the attack October 8th or was it
the 9th when he spoke out publicly about
it like there I didn't see him talking
about like well what happened happened
why was the why did the attack happen
for 6 hours why was there no IDF
response in 6 hours of of this just
raping and pillaging that these these
Hamas members were doing why was there
no defense I didn't hear any of that
from Ben it was just very much like we
need to go in they've done it to us now
get him and it was like I don't that was
a quick twist to authoritarian and if he
had his finger on the button that's
that's a temper I don't like I my view
would be a very simple if someone
attacks you stop them bring them to
justice
however I can see the arguments that are
happening now are much much much
different right uh you know your video
you're talking about ceasefire I think
the amount of Destruction that's that's
that's happening in Gaza is is is is
exceeding what I would describe as uh uh
proportional yeah I yes um I'm trying to
keep it very very very plain if you can
tell yeah the uh axiomatic line you have
to say uh if you support Israel is that
Israel has the right to defend itself
and in the abstract yeah of course uh
someone has a right to defend themselves
but what do we mean by that defense so
if this is October 7th and they're being
attacked by Hamas absolutely you have
the right to defend yourself but this
isn't October 7th anymore now this is a
month-long operation a carpet bombing of
Gaza as we're speaking more than 11,000
killed more than 4600 children I got I
got to push back on carpet yeah
technically I think it's not technical
carpet bombing because it's targeting
specific areas and then there's just
collateral damage carpet bombing would
be
targeting massive bombing of densely
populated area it it is yes massive
absolutely and what's missing from this
discussion is an acknowledgement that uh
before October 7th things weren't all
peachy for Israel's been occupying Gaza
and the West Bank for decades since 1967
and what is Gaza majority of it is
refugees and their descendants people
who are expelled ethnically cleansed by
Israel in
1948 and a country that is occupying
someone else doesn't have the right to
defend itself in order to perpetuate
that occupation if they're being
attacked on October 7th I understand you
defend your your people but after that
Israel's only obligation is to end the
occupation they don't have the they
don't have the right to bomb people uh
because they live in an area where some
militants fought back well the the first
thing I would say is I I I I I typically
am just at a loss for words in terms of
the moral arguments between two two
uh political bodies that are not the
United States and that have like nothing
to do with me and what I want or my
taxpayer dollars and where we don't
really speak those languages it's like
people are like we're paying for it
though we're giving the weapon so right
so my issue is like you got to justify
why we're doing that and why we spend
our tax dollars why why everyone in this
country is working so hard dealing with
with you know uh stagnant wages and high
cost of goods and then someone's going
to come and say we're going to give
whatever Israel we're going to give
Israel whatever they want I'm like
listen I certainly don't want Israel to
be destroyed I don't want Jews to be
targeted and killed I don't want
Palestinians dying but there's a war
over there so I'm just like the moral
arguments well Israel was there and they
were doing this I'm like look man that
means it means nothing to me right so if
an argument was hey you're an American
you pay taxes do you know do you do you
have a good answer for why it is a large
portion of your your savings are diluted
through this this policy of just Mass
spending deficit spending and giving
foreign countries military aid it's like
I don't really know then maybe we
shouldn't do that I know why it is for
Israel but if the argument is Israel is
morally bad for these reasons but wait
what about the Palestinians Hamas they
did these things and the people in Gaza
support I'm like well that's a debate
for the people who are at war with each
other and not for the United States how
about that it's interesting though I
mean if you like I was reading an
article in the Washington Post today
about um the pre-planning of the attack
on October 7th and apparently it was
like years in the making and there were
two years yeah it was like two years in
the making and there was I mean it's
sort of fascinating the um the planning
because they the intentions according to
this article were to go for for the for
the attackers to get all the way to the
West Bank that was part of their goal
and also to um sort of show some
Defiance to the Palestinian Authority in
the West Bank and also they were um they
had two it was like they had two books
two sets of books they had like the two
sets of communication they had the
communication with each other and the
communication that they knew Israel was
listening to um so it was very organized
but just to go back to what we were
talking about with the students for
justice in Palestine that is a national
movement they have chapters on campuses
all over the country and they're not a
not for-profit and the National
Organization is not a not for-profit
they are umbrell by an organization
called the Westpac foundation in
Westchester so they are able to take tax
deductible contributions and when those
students are saying that they are the
movement it's not a Grassroots students
for justice in Palestine is not a
Grassroots organization they said
Palestinians in Exile like they're
saying they're actual Palestinians who
are in support of sure I think they're
probably accurate with that and the that
that student group as well as Jewish
voices for peace was also banned on the
Columbia University and Barnard campuses
really what yeah yeah they staged a they
staged a whole well yeah they staged
like a what was it it was like a
national strike on Thursday and there
was some um there was some upsetness on
the campus and there were some sit-ins
so those groups were banned on the
Columbia campus as well I just I'm like
but it is part of like a National
Organization so it isn't just like
Banning you know it isn't just saying
like hey you formed this student group
and you you know got funds from the
student action committee or whatever it
is part of a a national very organized
group that has funding that we can't
track because they have an umbrella
group and they are basically an NG B
corporations from I'm not advocating for
or against I'm just in terms of War I do
not believe that morality is determined
based on the strength of a single party
so we'll get as specific as we can
Israel Palestine Israel is not wrong
because they're more powerful than
Palestine Israel wins a conflict and
that doesn't mean they're morally right
or wrong two different groups of people
are fighting for a variety of reasons
and uh and they believe they're right
and they're Justified many people would
agree with one side or the other and
they'll make those arguments here in the
United States and then fight about it my
view is kind of like don't know don't
know why I'm paying for it and just
because Israel is more powerful doesn't
mean they're inherently bad if two
groups are fighting I don't know what
you want me what you want me to do about
it there's there's really interesting
conundrums as as it pertains to how you
deal with these things let me let me let
me give you a scenario and and and ask
like it's not there's no there's no good
way to do a one for one analogy but here
an example would be there is a mass
shooter in a mall unloading an AR-15 at
at a bunch of buildings at a bunch of
different storefronts and he's hitting
several people a man runs up aims his
weapon at the shooter to stop him but he
standing in front of a crowd of people
is the answer do not shoot at him
because you will also hit the people
behind him
geez I'm not saying I'm I'm not I'm not
saying I know what is right or wrong I'm
saying the if the issue is it's the
trolley problem too but the analogy to
me is flaw because Hamas right now is
not uh a threat on mass the people of
Israel and also again before October 7th
Israel was occupying Gaza so if for
example what does that mean occupying uh
they had it besieged they had completely
cut it off from the world you couldn't
if you're in Gaza you're stuck there for
life you can't leave Israel controls
everything you do what about Egypt well
they had the Egypt also was
participating in the blockade right so
it's not just Israel it's Egypt too but
it's under Israeli control Israel Israel
has a list of everybody there Israel
Israel even calculated the amount of C
calories that people could eat without
fully starving but they were also
allowing all the money from Qatar to go
in like $30 million Netanyahu was
allowing cutter to pop up Hamas because
he saw Hamas as a way to undermine
international calls for a two State
solution because even though Hamas in
recent years has actually tried to
moderate his position and say they
accept a Palestinian state in the
occupied territories nahu rightly saw
their internal divisions and the
divisions inside the Palestinian
factions as a way to undermine calls for
a two-state solution so yes Netanyahu
and he said this at a meeting it was
quoted he said the way to stop a
Palestinian state is to prop up Hamas
Hamas also leader the Hamas leaders
according to this article I read today I
don't have a ton of information on this
but the Hamas leaders were saying that
they were advocating they were saying
like oh we're comfortable with peace
we're happy with the situation as it is
as they were planning the attack it was
like a like a diversion tactic listen I
think there's a split inside Hamas and I
think from what I understand and a lot
of the details of October 7th are still
murky uh we don't know exactly I think
the proportion of people for example who
were killed who on the Israeli side who
were military I don't deny there were
civilians killed in horrible atrocities
but we also don't know how many people
were killed by Israeli fire because we
know that is Israeli helicopters fired
on some of those areas where the Hamas
people were inside the Israeli kibot
teim and some of those people were
burned alive and I don't I don't think
Hamas Rockets could cause that I could
be wrong but what I'm saying is there's
a lot we don't know about October 7th we
do know there were atrocities by Hamas
that is clear but a lot of the details
are still unclear and ALS also what the
goals were of this operation
and there's a split inside Hamas there
are people inside Hamas who didn't even
know about this and there are people
inside Hamas who well the political
leaders right there are people inamas
who advocated accepting a Palestinian
state within the West Bank in Gaza other
people rejected that so I think I I
think it's hard to describe the movement
as a monolith the the question would be
who started the fight well I think the
fight started was was started by Israel
in 1948 when it was founded on ethnic
cleansing well that's the war that's
well okay so th this round of the fight
you could say yes Hamas did but again
these are not two equal sides one side
is what do equality matter in war well
because if you're a portioning blame uh
and you have one side that's occupying
another that's preventing people from
leaving from living normal lives Egypt
Egypt was participating in the but so
but Israel open up the Rafa Crossing and
say everyone you're free to they could
let everyone flee but then that's a
dilemma because then you're basically
accepting Israel's ethnic cleansing
goals Israel wants to drive all those
people out which it's doing now and so
Egypt yes Egypt totally complicit and so
both Egypt and Israel at odds with each
other and the gazin are caught in the
middle yes but again Israel is the
occupying power Israel controls the
everything that gets into Gaza the uh
the fuel uh even theal supplies like
Israel won't allow Egypt to allow things
in uh Egypt being uh a US client state
which gets a lot of money from the US
and doesn't want to do anything to defy
the US basically obeyed orders but and
so yes Egypt has plenty of complicity I
I've no
kind things to say about them but Israel
is the power that displaced all these
people in Gaza to begin with has
occupied them has besieged them has
routinely attacked them this is not the
first Israeli attack on Gaza there's
been many and all this has been done
with the goal of solidifying Israeli
settler cloning ISM which goes back to
Israel's founding so in terms of who
started the fight I think it starts with
Israel and it's their obligation so you
said 1948 yeah what started that fight
well then you have a zist movement
recognizing that there are people inside
the land of Palestine which they want to
colonize uh jabotinsky was an early
Zionist leader said Zionism is a
colonizing project uh Lord Balor who's
the British official who promised a
Jewish homeland in Palestine said with
that letter with that letter he said
we're going to you know I'm paraphrasing
him he said we're going to go ahead with
this because even though yes this isn't
this isn't a inconvenient or it's a
hindrance to the Arabs who live there
but the Zionist project is more
important and so when you deny people
the right to nationhood in their own
land there's going to be a problem and
Israel accomplished that with ethnic
cleansing that's that's not a dispute
now and then in 1967 Israel then brings
millions of more people under occupation
in the West Bank in Gaza and ever since
then it's been this current phase of
outright military occupation and yes
Israel withdrew from Gaza in 2005 but
really that was just the occupation just
in a different guys so my my view on
this is uh the fight didn't start in
right okay I mean the the fight just
goes back at infinum to the dawn of time
basically to the to the to the years of
of biblical Legend it goes before that
go well before that the kingdom of Judea
existed there were my thing is just like
according to the Bible according to the
Bible no no according to like genetic
history 90,000 years there have been
hominids living there 90,000 years yeah
and like I'm not talking about the Bible
I'm talking about the fact that like
Jews lived there yeah thousands of years
ago at the start of the 20th century
there was I don't know the the number of
the the percentage of Jews in Palestine
I think was maybe 5% maybe even less
than that and then you had and I I
understand this because I know my
history of Jewish people a lot of
persecution and that increased support
for this idea of a Jewish homeland which
certainly ramped up with the Nazi
Holocaust so you had a huge migration in
the 20th century of Jews to Palestine
and but before that though you had times
when Jews and and Palestinians were
living in uh in relative peace and the
conflict only comes with the Zionist
project with this attempt to colonize
Palestine I heard uh that when balur
Arthur balfor signed the balfor
Declaration during World War I and
basically screwed the Arabs out of
Palestine they were like hey Arabs
betray the Ottomans and we'll give you
that land the Arabs like okay they
betrayed the Ottomans the British won
the war and then the British were like
psych we're keeping it for ourselves
that is what led to the Germans hating
the Jewish people leading up to World
War II so created all this they were
like they stole it the Zion they created
a land of Israel like these Jewish so
that's where all this this Jew German
hate just something I heard recently it
made total sense I mean but like what a
screw over they lost World War I because
it the land with there were like pug RS
in the Middle Ages you it's been going
on for thousands of years way even
before I mean German sentiment yeah I
mean there was all this stuff also in
the Middle Ages um Jews in Europe for
the most part were not allowed to um own
property and so that's why you have such
a that's why you ended up with a history
of Jews involved in banking and lending
it's cuz they weren't allowed to own
property so they had to find some other
way to make an income my my I'm just
thinking like what what's the
solution well listen for me ideally it
would be equality for everybody because
I don't believe in the supremacy of of
any ethnicity even though there's a big
history of of persecution of Jews let me
ask you question so that's my ideal but
the international consensus has long
been a two-state solution and so that
would be like the West Bank and Gaza
being connected by that that little
travel Corridor or something and remove
all the Israeli settlements why should
somebody from settlements where in the
in the occupied West Bank why should
somebody from Brooklyn
have more rights than the people who've
lived there forever they took all the
settlements out of Gaza I mean they
evicted yes they did and they put Gaza
under a medieval blockade uh and in fact
what I'm saying is they took all the
settlements out yes they did but none
that means anything because right now
there are people who live in houses and
they they have they they they're not
party to what you're describing someone
maybe like moved in later and got a
house and they live somewhere the the
the kutzas in in in Israel that got
attacked these are some of these people
are just like I bought a house I don't
know yeah so what what would happen do
you think if the barriers around Gaza
were completely removed and Israel said
all people of Gaza are free to move
about the state of Israel well if Israel
did that and they finally took
responsibility ask I'm saying what what
Happ if they just moved the barricades
and said everyone you're free to move as
you please well uh at this point now
people are so destitute they'd be
looking for water and food so after you
shorted that out and people actually got
their basic needs which Israel is
depriving them of um look I've been to
Gaza I've been to the West Bank people
just want to live in Peace and Freedom
would would the would the people go back
to the land they believe belongs to them
and their ancestors unless Israel uh
tried to have a just resolution to that
which also is the international
consensus Palestinians have the right to
return they were removed now you could
argue now that's no longer feasible it's
true I'm not giving up my home now to an
indigenous person even though an
indigenous person lived there I'm sure
before and were ethnically cleansed a
long time ago so we recognize that
historical injustices happened
and you have to find a a way to
address to address it in a fair way but
the problem is Israel Israel's never
accepted responsibility but it doesn't
matter because you can't well you but
you can at least uh accept
responsibility for the ethnic cleansing
here now we here now we acknowledge that
this land was created on on Stolen
indigenous land Israel could do the same
thing we don't that I don't acknowledge
that at
all no chance no chance I I do for what
it's worth and and many people they
bought Manhattan Manhattan was paid for
legally okay
okay let's not debate that the point is
if if you accept the historical truth
that there was ethnic cleansing in 1948
people don't they're just okay well then
you can go to the Israeli archives and
read all about it Benny Morris who's the
top Israeli historian who supports this
project says it was a good thing say
says it didn't go far enough his term is
ethnic purification but none of that
matters well it does matter because if
Israel took responsibility for it
finally and said we stole your homes
we're sorry for it now we have a problem
where we have all these people here we
built up a state we're not going to let
everyone come back but we will
compensate for you and apologize that
that could be a starting point that does
not solve the problem it could well so
the alternative is what permanent
occupation I'm not saying I have a
solution I'm saying the idea what I'm
proposing is take responsibility
apologize and remove all the settlements
from the West Bank that and and so that
means there are people who are there who
have no idea like yes they got a house
and they moved in they were like wow
we're moving into a house and now it's
like the government's going to come and
take their land from them and then and
then you know what they're going to do
they're going to say my land was taken
from me by the government in some
ridiculous deal that I don't agree with
and then they're going to start except
there's something there we go under
international law you cannot build up
territory you've acquired by force it's
a pretty basic but is the government
doing it the isra government and and so
a civilian who gets a house yes what
happens to them and their property and
their net worth and their I am not
saying what's happening there put them
back in in 1948 Israel which again
doesn't matter that's a meaning that
means nothing Well Israel you can't you
can't you can't go back and say well
back then someone is something I'm
saying right now Israel has recognized
International boundaries right right now
nobody nobody recog the geography of
what it was in no but doesn't mean
anything nobody recognizes Israel you're
not going to take someone's house from
them it's not going to work you're going
to get Bloodshed first of all Israel
takes Palestinians homes all the time
it's bad and it's Bloodshed yeah all the
time so now if the argument
is equality for all everyone can return
okay then what's going to happen is that
wasn't my argument you said I me ideally
for me ideally I said it should be uh
equality for all cuz I believe all
people are creat equal so why wouldn't I
support that but it's not practical I
agree with that the implication is the
right of return that there's land now
where israelies live yes and the
Palestinians would get to return to that
land displacing the people who live I'm
saying you recognize the right and you
now uh just because you recognize a
right that doesn't mean you fully
Implement everything that comes with it
and you at least though you have to if
there's a historical Injustice and it's
still causing so much you have to at
least recognize it right and so if
Israel came out and said yes we stole
your land yes we occupied you and you
and we're not going to give it back you
think that's going to that's going to be
like well we're cool thank you very much
and have a nice day well listen I
understand why Palestine would never
accept that because their land was
stolen from them if you meet so many
Palestinians still have the keys to
their homes I'm trying to think of a
practical solution to to this horrible
problem and ideally I think everyone
should have the right to come back to
their homes because I do I I do believe
in equality if we accept though that
Israel has these recognized boundaries
and Israel's nuclear weapons and so the
idea of getting them to accept equality
is pretty impractical then at least at
minimum the very minimum you should that
we should do is recognize the historical
Injustice that's happened to
Palestinians and then work within that
to find a solution and to me it's based
international law the settlements have
no right to be there remove all of them
what right what does that mean so you
can't build up your population in
territory you've stolen so are Jews are
not indigenous to the Middle
East I know there's a there's been a
small Jewish population in the Middle
East for a long time but you know like
do I look like I come from the Middle
East I mean you you meet many Jews
they're from Ukraine they're from
they're from Eastern Europe like this
idea that like how far back do we go to
if someone came to your house holding up
a Bible and saying Hey My My family
lived here 3,000 years ago 2,000 years
ago does that give you a right but does
that give them a right to come and take
your home because that's basically like
the Z so what is the time frame then 50
years yeah I mean we're in this modern
era of the you know of the United
Nations Israel was recognized by the UN
within certain bord ERS not within the
West Bank and Gaza it 50 years then if
it's 50 years then give it 50 years and
then there'll be total peace you're
right okay so I agree let's say in 50
years we'll just call the land the land
and we're done and then it's peaceful
everyone's happy you're asking me for
Solutions right now right the issue is I
think what I'm proposing is a historic
compromise and I'm not sure Palestinians
would even accept it because their land
is all of Palestine they were there they
were ethnically cleansed we're asking
them to accept 22% of historic Palestine
and Israel with us backing are such
Fanatics they couldn't even give
Palestinians that all these claims that
the Palestine Palestines have been
offered a generous peace deal of the
state it's all a lie Israel's never been
willing to give up control of the major
West Bank settlements that's the problem
here what you think about Burma what do
you think about Burma yeah I don't have
a strong opinions about Burma why do you
think how about aeran and Armenia that's
a fascinating situation I think that was
a horrible thing that happened uh I'm
I'm also not as familiar with it as just
like I don't understand why people are
just like Israel 110% everything about
it all the time and I'm just like bro
I'm sitting here in America like I don't
know why we're us is funding it us
provides funding to to Armenia and did
you know this is insurgencies have been
going on in Myanmar since
198 and there's several hundred, dead
since then and this year alone I think
it's been twice there's one is there one
US politician or corporate media pun who
goes on TV and uh the point the point is
like why why is it because we're
responsible for it and because the the
Injustice you figure out a way that
we're responsible for me andmar too I'm
sure sure that we had our hands in there
somewhere all I'm saying is like we need
to get back to America First and I'm
sure at at the bare minimum like the
there are many people who I see are like
very critical of Israel and I'm like I
don't know what that's all about and I
don't want to get into a moral argument
should the US stop funding everything
outside the United States and go back to
securing its borders building up jobs
here helping the working class maybe
fixing some of the pipes and the roads
and infrastructure we can agree because
would the people were like stop funding
Israel and I'm like stop funding
everything but what about Puerto Rico
Puerto Rico not a state but should we
stop funding them no Puerto Rico is
awesome Puerto Rico so Israel is kind of
like a client state of the US ter do you
think that the it's technically a
country but it's used like a a territory
of the United States they're American
citizens they they they R is Puerto Ric
said Israel Israel is Puerto Ric a state
no no no no that's I mean maybe I'm just
saying they vote on that every now and
then defunding Israel would be like
Puerto Ric tax in the in the in the
minds of the media and the people that
are running the government defunding
Israel would be like defunding Puerto
Rico they use it like a client well I
see what you're saying but uh the thing
about Puerto Rico is that the US has a
ton of territorial islands and they're
all not going to become States there's a
lot of complicated legal nonsense
pertaining to to to the creation of a
new state whether Puerto Rico should
become a state and the big issue right
now is I don't think the US is actually
able to solve its own Regional problems
with like greater Idaho and Northern
californ that's a fascinating situation
too the uh the Oregon counties that want
to suceed Bringing bringing Puerto Rico
in as a state would would further
destabilize an already tumultuous
situation in the United States so that's
why I say maybe maybe in the future but
for for now but let let's do this let's
let's shift into uh some domestic
politics and we'll uh we'll get off
yelling about Israel again I love
domestic politics here we go outrage is
San Francisco boots vagrants off streets
ahead of xiin ping visit as California
governor gav ism admits woke city was
only given polish to impress world
leaders oh we got the clip for you I'm
going to play it cuz it's hilarious here
we go I know folks say oh they're just
cleaning up this place cuz all those
fancy leaders are coming into town um
that's
true because it's true that's that's
what it takes gu but it's also true for
months and months and months prior to
ape we've been having different
conversations all right so here's what I
want to say uh imagine having a roommate
there's pizza boxes everywhere the
dishes are all dirty there's Grime
everywhere and you go dude I'm paying
rent too clean up your mess they like
I'll do it man chill and then one day
the dude freaks out and like dude my
mom's coming over and starts cleaning up
you'd be like WTF man you'd be so mad
like I'm glad you're cleaning up I'm
glad you're cleaning up but you should
have cleaned this place up a long time
ago and this proves you could have done
it I guess the difference in the analogy
is the argument is oh it's so hard to
deal with and how do we help these
people and then what did they do they
put a bunch of like horse troughs along
the street to block tents did they go at
4:30 in the morning with fire hoses and
hit them all because they've done that
before they did that in Atlanta before
the Olympics remember they like CED
every cleared everybody out full on fire
hosing people's tents and destroying in
New York a lot of times they just give
people a bus ticket and they're like get
the hell out of here what's up with that
that fire that Homeless encampment that
in La that fire that that also like a it
was like a massive fire and it also
melted the freeway and the freeway is
now unusable honestly that's happened so
many times remember during the pandemic
like I would literally be driving around
La and there would be usually a be on
the highway somewhere it would be a fire
underneath an overpass it's like a
regular thing that I saw many many many
times I was driving out of DC last week
uh with my son and he was in the car and
he was just like whoa what's with all
these tents why are there all these
people just sleeping out here in the
street and I was like that's our
nation's capital hun this I got we got
going on so many people earlier you
mentioned like we're all equal you were
talking about equality and like being
there for all of us but how do you deal
with this excess of humanity that lives
off of the tit or just is like sick and
they just live on the street like what
are you what's your proposition I don't
refer to unhoused people as the excess
of humanity the people who are excess of
humanity the people who are destroying
this Earth the warmongers the people who
are using populations as sacrificial
lambs and killing them like Israel is
doing like what's happening in in
Ukraine so but but basically I connect
this to foreign policy instead of
spending all this money on arming Israel
and also arming Ukraine why can't we
build um homes for people who need them
well I like that that's not a solution
uh why first so I used to work for a
homeless uh nonprofit the first question
I have to ask is why is a person
homeless and it's typically not because
they're poor it's there there's other
underlying factors that result that's
what I mean by the excess of human
people that are B Gone broken but right
so so the issue is if you take a
homeless person and put him in a house
house falls apart house burns down uh
electrical problems plumbing problems
maintenance taxes prop taxes you can't
just make a house and put somebody in it
okay so give them Services too like fund
Social Services support people who need
it and now here's where I'll agree with
you I would love to uh apply a wealth
tax but only to the uh uh military
industrial complex corporations I would
love to uh uh strip the wealth and tax
at 100% all the
warmongers and take all of their money
and literally I would totally be okay
with this hand it out in cash to a to
random homeless people but then they
wouldn't be making profit don't I am
saying I would rather a crazy homeless
guy walking around just spitting have a
$100,000 in cash stuffed in his pockets
if if it means the military industrial
complex is not funding and starting more
needless nonsense Wars be we'd be way
less in debt bullish on the milit
industrial complex these days think
about the economic boom of all the
homeless people buying cheeseburgers and
sub sandwiches subways up everywhere so
when I said excess of humanity I I just
mean that I finding that some people
have either gone totally psychotic due
to drugs or like lack of connection with
humanity and they've just gone into wild
feral mode like what do we do and and
they don't want they on the street
they don't want to get a job they don't
want to take a shower they they're
looking for their next fix they carry
sharp blades on them like what do we do
about this well a lot of people would
say also that those people who are you
know living rough as you would say or
sleeping rough that they should be
allowed to do that that they shouldn't
have to be forced into society's way
right like shouldn't there be a place
where people who don't want to conform
to society's standards can exist
differently okay then what we do is
probably shouldn't be on the city
streets we go to Wyoming and we take
like 400 acres and then we say like here
after after a certain amount of time of
you being unhoused in this area you will
be given a a structure in the middle of
Wyoming and best of luck to you that
would be an interesting weird Kafka
scenario that would be that would lead
to like some serious what Shirley
Jackson style novels coming out sounds
like gogs sounds pretty weird I say I
didn't say they were they were forced to
stay there I we give you a house what do
mean here's a bus ticket here is a here
is a structure for which you can live
but it's in Wyoming you can leave
whatever you want there's an interesting
thing too like in in uh you probably saw
this in Chicago over the weekend some
people who were in Chicago illegal
immigrants from Venezuela they were like
we don't like it here it's cold and we
can't get going back right and they're
like we're going home and in New York
they um uh governor governor mayor Adams
turned uh Floyd Bennett Field basically
into a tent city and so some people were
moved out of their shelters and they
went to this Tent City in Floyd Bennett
Field and they got off the bus and they
were like we don't want to be out here
it's out like it's the old JFK Airport
basically let me ask you Aon you said
unhoused they want to go does that mean
why do you say that way that's the term
now for homeless people but why that's
the new politically correct term Tim get
with it no no no no but I'm asking cuz
you you used it I'm just doing what I'm
told that's the term so you know do you
support as somebody who has done
advocacy for the homeless I think it's
offensive really okay yeah I think what
the left has done is try to uh sweep the
problem under the rug exemplified by
exactly what the Democratic super
majority of Los Angeles does every
single time the issue comes up not in my
backyard they they all stand up and they
scream look at San Francisco look at the
look at the problems of homelessness and
then what happens Shan p showing up
shove it all into the rug every policy
I've seen did you know that there are
more empty houses than there are
homeless people and I'm like what do you
what are you saying you want to just
take a homeless person and put them in a
house you know what you're doing you're
shoving the problem under the rug you're
saying we don't want these people to be
seen in our streets stick them in a
house somewhere well now the naive might
be like no no we're giving them a house
sure but anybody who owns a house knows
how difficult it is to maintain a house
everybody knows well not everybody
agrees with property taxes but property
taxes exist for a reason for supporting
the road and the community and the
schools and things like this the the
average homeless person is is not
homeless because they're like you know I
just lost my job and now I'm you know
hard times and if only had an
opportunity those people certainly exist
and what I encountered when it came to
homeless people having worked for for
various homeless nonprofits and and
advocacy nonprofits is young people who
choose to be homeless but they want to
be there's a group in in in Seattle
called the avats train Hoppers people
who are in their late teens early 20s
who are intentionally homeless
and you would never get them into a
house and then we encountered like 80%
of the homeless people are uh mentally
unwell to the point where if you put
them in a house and did not have a
worker who was maintaining that house
and and caring for them the house would
probably burn down but burned down or
flood they'd turn the the stove on maybe
or they turn the water on you know uh we
had an issue where this is this is scary
stuff for homeowners water was left on
and the and the drain wasn't going down
and then after like 30 minutes all of
the ceiling of the basement or I
shouldn't say all but like 30% destroyed
just because the drain wasn't going down
properly and it poured over the sink I'm
like that's crazy so we we've dealt with
all of this like uhoh we put a homeless
guy in a house he turned the bathtub on
it overflowed the house got flooded
destroyed everything the house is
unlivable if he stays there he'll die
well we lost that house what do we do
it's really you know it is the whole
house thing like I've lived in
apartments the whole time and now I have
a house and recently like you know
there's been like an issue here or there
and I'm like damn it I really I really
wish I could call the super wish there
was a landlord call Super in this
building and be like hey this isn't
working you need to come up and fix this
blah blah blah anyway my point is it was
it was always really frustrating for me
when I'm like wow we've raised x amount
of dollars to help the homeless what are
we doing mental health programs the
shelters are actually not houses they're
like beds and community centers it is so
hard to get them to come why no Freedom
can't do drugs you can't drink and some
of these guys just can't think properly
there was one guy I remember
encountering who had a bottle of wine he
was trying to open it was corked and he
wasn't I don't even know what he was
doing and I was like hey man you all
right and he goes AB Baba and I was like
there's nothing I can say to this man
and I don't want to get into it because
you know what happens he might get
agitated he might get angry and then we
got a situation so I'm out I'm out
there's definitely so what would you
propose as as a solution I mean you've
worked with this community directly so
what would you uh support So any
Sheltering that we have to do and this
this is the this is the Big Challenge
the answer is always going to be a level
of force meaning if someone is a
recurring homeless person living in an
area they are forcefully detained they
are taken from the area and said you
cannot live on the street it is it is
creating disease we saw the we saw the
emergence of typhus in California
because of the expansion of the homeless
population it is a detriment to you it
is a detriment to us and why do we stop
people from doing certain drugs same
argument it's it's it's you're gonna
harm yourself and others I'm actually in
favor of most drugs being legal to
varying degrees so this is is tough and
this is the the the the serious and
difficult position is should the state
arrest and I don't mean like criminally
arrest I mean like restrict the movement
of and forcefully detain a person who is
persistently homeless and if the if if
you want to solve the problem that's
what you have to do what San Francisco
does and many of these other places do
is they load them up up on load them up
on buses and send them somewhere far
away and then just cross their fingers
the problem doesn't come back what how
did San Francisco deal with the homeless
problem well all I know is video one
shows a bunch of tents video two shows a
bunch of horse troughs full of water
blocking where the tents used to be
which likely indicates the government
came by force removed all the tents
kicked everybody out destroyed
everything and then put up these horse
troughs so sh and ping could come here
in peace I don't think that's good all
they're doing is saying F you to the
homeless people but if we made Community
uh communal shelter
where if you are persistently homeless
you will be brought you can't leave then
we're talking about some kind of it's
going to require a due process system
it's going to require legislation and
unfortunately either you remove these
people forcefully and place them
somewhere where they will be under
better control or you do what San
Francisco did and just boot them out and
then have them wander somewhere else
here myal my proposal is this let's put
all the effort that we put into
warmongering funding these proxy wars in
Ukraine uh funding uh Israel to bomb
people of god let's put all the money we
put into that into a huge effort to give
people shelter and give people the
social services and support they need
because as you say uh a lot of people
are dealing with serious mental uh
illness issues drug addiction trauma
let's try to address that first and if
that doesn't work if after like we
actually do like a a warlike eort like a
huge effort if that doesn't work then
okay I think you an argue for using some
coion I completely disagree because
don't go far enough the warmongers
should also be put up on stage and
everyone gets the point and laugh at
them as their wealth is taken from them
warer in the Puritan New England I think
that there are definitely some things
that should be done in order to prevent
homelessness even as difficult as it is
to solve homelessness like there should
be housing for um kids that age out of
foster care like you should get
somewhere to live if you're 18 and
you're no longer in the foster care
system like those people like if you if
you come out of foster care you're 18
you're not going to college you have no
money you have no resources the real
solution the city should help you get a
house like somewhere to live the real
solution you're not hom it's a cultural
issue and I think the real problem is
humans will not accept what this is
going to become that's just it you mean
like the whole the whole there is no
acceptable moral position in the
homelessness problem we're facing right
now that any group would be okay with
that's just it forceful relocation and
arrest of homeless is shocking and
terrifies people because how do you how
do you enact that that that system well
there what a person gets arrested
accused of dereliction and then they're
brought before a judge to prove whether
or not they're destitute and then you
don't have enough money so now you're
getting now you're going to be locked up
or something that's terrifying and scary
some people choose to be vagabonds and
they're not the same as a person who's
taking a dump on the sidewalk but what
you're going to get arrested it's a
horrifying Circumstance the other thing
is with the degree Dee of homelessness
we've seen in LA and in San Francisco
and Sacramento it has gotten so bad with
the human waste again this is 5 years
ago the the reemergence of typhoid and
Bubonic plague starting starting to
emerge in California and so what happens
the you're going to get a Hunger Games
or like elisium style world where the
ultra wealthy will build Bridges between
skyscrapers so they don't have to go
onto the ground level where all the
feces and disgust is or the government
comes and sweeps everybody out which
you're poison both are dystopian and hor
what do you think about reopening the
mental institutions that's been talked
about by the Republicans talking about
that
yeah you know I don't know enough about
that but I do know that people
definitely need support and there has to
be a humane way to do that and the
people who work on the ground are the
best advocates for that and the best
experts on that I know plenty of people
who work with the unhoused who have all
kinds of ideas and talk about the needs
that people have and how they're not
being addressed because there just isn't
the funding for it so how about we try
that first how about we try to put some
serious effort into this issue treat it
just as Ser treat it more seriously than
we do treating the need to fight Foreign
Wars and bomb people I got I got to stop
UNH thing dude do a real effort the the
unhoused thing is like I I think it's
leftist double speak to
manipulate uh public policy positions
because you don't like Define house
right so what we're saying is somebody
who lives in some kind of structure but
it's not a house so they unhoused what's
a home right it's it's it's saying
unhoused is applying a material position
and and and and like a resource number
to what a person is required to have I'm
personally not offended by the term
homeless I'm fine to use it but given
that that's what people who I know who
work on this issue use I just follow
their lead unhoused you don't need a
house I've heard people that live on
stre you can live in someone else's
couch and be and be homeless okay so
like the when when you say someone's
unhoused it's the implication that they
should be housed but what
like why should they be house you you
you deserve a house you you deserve a
home somewhere to live yes a home is
different from a house okay sure I'm but
I'm happy to call it unhomed if that you
know no I think it's just I think it's
manipulative double speak to control a
narrative and shift and gradually shift
positions dud that give people houses or
people that have slept on the street
that say I have a home and it's right
over there on Fifth Avenue so don't call
me homeless and I'm like well you're
sleeping out in the open and it's like
yeah but that's my home if you rent your
friend's couch are you homeless no you
have a home it's your your couch but
you're un technically not you would be
on housed yes you would I I don't I
don't like this manipulative double
speak where they change language and
change the definition don't need
paperwork to have a home or a house you
just need to literally be some but the
issue ultimately comes down to what do
you say to a man of sound mind who
chooses to not have a home and live
outside don't poop on my street that's
number one I watched a homeless person
from my window one time poop on my car
yeah some I called I called the police
and I said hey
I I don't know if this concerns you
there's a person pooping on my car what
should I do and they were like you got a
hose and I was like no I don't I don't
got a hose and they were like well you
might want to get a hose sooner than
later cuz that stuff's acrylic yeah it
wasn't acidic it wasant if somebody if
somebody makes the choice to not have a
home and they're so resourceful and so
skilled that they can live out in the
world like that I say respect I mean
good for you that's that's I could never
do that I don't say it
again but I don't think that's what most
you know I don't think most people who
live on the streets I don't think it's a
it's a choice I think they're put there
by circumstances beyond their control
when I when I worked for the shelter
Network I did 80% was a choice yeah I
think % 80% do you understand why that's
hard to believe because you've never
worked in the industry and you don't
know anything about you don't have no
idea I did spend a summer this is I'm
sorry I I spent one summer working with
the UNH house population who you you
think a guy but it sounds like you have
more experience than I do because I just
spent one summer I it's just like
walking walk go to California go to La
uh go to go like West go some areas in
Westwood I know UC UC Al is up there so
you don't they push a lot of the stuff
out but I remember going to a shopping
center somewhere uh where was I um
somewhere near Hollywood slightly west
of Hollywood and it's like five homeless
guys all living up against side of a
building and a and a lady gets out of
the tent walks in the middle of the
street just takes a dump yeah and when
you go to them and be like we got a bed
we got a private room and they say F you
cuz the shelters are terrible they've
all probably had terrible experience
some of them are houses some of them are
full houses a five-bedroom house and
you'd go to someone and be like how
would you like keys to a house and a
bedroom and they go you got a manager
there I'm like we do never going to
happen we're like well I don't know what
to tell you man okay so look I can't
extrapolate based on that that that
applies then to the majority of the
community I I just can't AR maybe you're
right but regardless why not try at
least why not give the opp allit are
doing well I think they're working
within a very tough system to do what
they can but they have the resources I
think the problem is Democrat we're
spending all our money on Wars so
there's not there's not enough to give
people there I I don't know if it's a
one for one but I would agree with not
spending money on Wars and at least and
giving a shot no let me tell you I'll
tell you this I would take every single
penny from every single warmonger and I
would give it to one homeless guy who
couldn't think straight because I'm just
like I can't stand this it's we're
better off we're better off because in
the long run we save money if we're
engage leg print 3D print graphine homes
for people but the key is to get them in
to get them to want to take a shower and
join the system when people are already
checked out of the system had we had
some people who would stay in the there
were forever shelters and there were
temporary shelters and if you were a
consistent temporary shelter individual
they could upgrade you or move you to
the permanent shelter there were
legitimate people that I have met who
were like man I lost my job and I have
no friends and I don't know how to do
anything like you you get me a job I'll
do whatever it takes these people have
recovered but these people don't exist
as much in like the reason why
homelessness tends not to be that is
because those people will give the
opportunity to leave instantly a guy is
homeless for two weeks the shelter comes
up and says we want to help you he goes
please I'll take whatever you got three
months later he's got a he's sharing an
apartment with a with with some other
guys a couple hundred bucks a month no
longer a homeless problem but the reason
why most homel people see in the street
are there is because they want to stay
there and don't want to leave in Chicago
for instance they use these Bridges to
make little Villages and they in between
each pillar there's like so the way it
works is there's sidewalk and there's an
elevated portion with pillar and they
set up beds in between each section you
will never get them to move Jane's right
there John's across the street this is
my town and so they're covered in urine
there's feces everywhere they dump in
the streets and you show up and say we
want to help you and they go help with
what we want to give you a home and help
you get out of the situation I like my
situation have a nice day leave and so
now we have the problem problem of like
in California tents everywhere in DC
it's happening tents everywhere and it's
leading to uh needles in the streets I
we we went to man it's it's such it's so
brutal with this really nice little
historic town in Maryland and there was
I took a picture syringes and condoms on
the ground and I'm like it's because we
we've become and this this is why I say
there's no moral answer Americans do not
want to accept that you need some kind
of
like harsh force and Authority when it
comes to what people are doing in public
y That's what come down it used to be
people wearing suits everywhere they
went in the early 1900s and hats don't
know about all that love but there was
heavy heavy social and police
enforcement you're walking around drunk
drunk in public they would lock you up
they still do sort of to this say
depending on the degree of drunkenness
but most people just ignore it now in my
experience people who are dealing with
addiction and me and mental illness and
other self-defeat really self-harmful
Behavior are dealing with trauma
something really bad that's happened to
them from a very very young age
and what I would want to do in any kind
of effort to alleviate homelessness is
address that and it's not I I agree with
you that providing shelter in a home is
not is not a Panacea it's not a one siiz
fits all policies it have to come with
addressing the issues that make people
destitute and desperate in the first
place and that's a lot of that has to do
with suffering terrible experiences from
a very very young age or at some point
in their lives cultural shifts and if
you deal psychological trauma and if you
deal with that then you might be to have
the kind of shift that I think you're
talking about I can't vouch for your
statistics I mean you you've worked I'm
talking about one city by the way I'm
not talking about like every city in the
country or everywhere I've been but but
you're saying that if you went around to
all the people in LA and offered them
you know a home a place to live my
friend if you went the majority would
not accept it absolutely no question I
mean look and worse still you might get
physically hurt yeah I and it's not
because every single homeless person is
V I'm saying it's because there there's
a viral video of a a homeless guy what
did you guys see this video he had the
knife and he was swinging at the lady
who lived in the building because some
people are crazy and if you have 3,000
homeless people and you go around asking
each and every one of them you
eventually counter someone who gets
agitated and crazy they're scared
because I mean they'll take your stuff
from you they'll they'll try and control
you they'll take away your drugs they'll
tell you what you can and can't do
they'll tell you when you can go outside
and when you can't go outside yeah so
nobody wants to be in these situations
but if you tell someone we've got a
place for you to sleep you can get
cleaned up they'll say okay and then
they'll start using it to amplify the
negative behaviors that were causing the
problems in the first place well then i'
want to know why they have that drive to
perpetuate their negative behaviors and
I would bet why do drugs I would bet in
100 in 100% of cases it's because of
trauma because they've suffered
something horrible in their lives and
this is their way of dealing with it you
know we can see that for people of
privilege when they have an issue that's
self-defeating they have some sort of
adverse childhood experience that
they're not dealing with so I'd want to
know in every case what what caus
someone to be so self harmful to
themselves and other people and I I have
a friend who volunteers every Saturday
uh with homeless people in LA and he has
a different picture of the community he
serves than you've had and I'm I'm not
trying to um you know negate your point
you have your experience and I respect
it I just think certain things that
would need to happen to address this
issue haven't been tried I I try to
interface with the broken people
one-on-one and it's not scalable after I
like really emotionally connected with
like 50 broken humans I started to go
insane and I had to stop I almost killed
myself because it was so much pain I had
to had to empathize with so much pain so
that's not a sustainable and then I'm
just like should we just be like those
sometimes humans walk so far
psychologically they just walked off a
cliff now they're feral and we got to
treat them like wild animals or or can
every human be reach I think that's a
possibility but why shouldn't we do all
we can to try why not we put so much
effort into war why can't we try to do
everything we can to I actually think uh
it is our incessant need to try and help
actually which is is what contributing
massively to the problem and what I mean
by that is we have created a society
where we've enabled Mass homelessness
through these programs if there was no
food and no one gave them food then they
would just simply stop and it's and and
it's like the argument now as why I said
there's no moral answer humans would be
willing to accept um the the there's
there's activist groups like food not
bombs and they're like did you know it's
illegal to give home people food it's
really funny because you have these uh
signs in the forest everywhere saying do
not feed Bears they'll become dependent
and dangerous yet you also have leftwing
activists who are like we should set up
a bunch of food and give food out to
people which is also particularly
offensive as I have actually having been
an unhoused person several times in my
life the implication that I was hungry
simply because I didn't have my own
place to live is like offensive like
what do you mean I was I was playing
guitar in the subway once I was not
homeless and a woman asked me if I was
hungry and I said no but thank you for
asking and and then she asked me if I
needed a place to sleep and I said it
was really funny I was playing guitar
making pretty decent money and I was
just like I appreciate the sentiment but
I'm going to go back to my two-bedroom
in Bucktown and and just play video
games tonight and she went huh like the
assumption that people who are playing
music in the street separate side note
are homeless the assumption that someone
who might be homeless is also hungry
these are these are all completely
incorrect things and I think it stems
from these these uh well-to-do liberal
types in cities want to help and I can
respect it but they actually make the
problem worse but why not be touched
that someone feels compelled to try to
help somebody out even if they got you
wrong they read you wrong that uh to try
to help you I think is a nice thing so I
I'm not saying it's not but if there's a
dude who is constantly doing drugs and
you're like you know what these drugs
are really bad for him but I'm going to
help him make sure he gets he gets the
drugs done right like I don't know if
you're actually helping the guy I think
you well it depends how he's using if
he's using dirty water to you know uh
inject heroin then if you're giving him
clean needles I I do think that's
helping him because you're preventing
him from possibly you're helping to
prevent him from Poss or you can just
stop him from doing drugs well you can't
do that though because the question is
um why is he why is he doing drugs in
the first place and 100% of the time
it's because of some trauma and I'm very
biased on
this I'm very biased on this because I
have a father who works on this stuff
but do you know do you know what caused
like the opioid crisis what caused the
opioid crisis so a large component of
what's of what causes it is someone gets
injured they get prescribed opioids and
they get addicted and they can't get off
then when the doctor Cuts them off
abruptly they go seek Black Market means
of getting it and creates a bunch of
criminals so it's it's not so much about
trauma but but not everyone who gets
injured gets addicted to opioid the
question is but a lot of people got
prescribed it and the prescriptions
turned into addiction not trauma be
physical trauma you know that bear the
company that made aspirin um created
heroin and started marketing it to
people who were addicted to
morphine get them off doctors wereing is
certainly huge problem but the question
is why is there that what does like look
addiction drugs it gives you a dopamine
rush and then you get addicted to that
why do you have a need for a dopamine
rush and there's plenty of research on
this I recommend my dad's work on this
his name is Gabor matate he's a oh I
love his work man I've been seeing him
all over TV lately yeah so you anyway
but I'm not going to speak for his work
but I'm just saying is consider the
possibility the people who are addicted
it's it's not the drugs in of themselves
it's what the drugs are doing for their
pain and I think unless you address that
you're not going to be able to the issue
there's a video I recorded uh what was
it um I guess I record it today it's
going to go up Friday because it's my
it's my one of my cultural segments and
it's a woman being like I have to work
so that I can buy a house so that I can
live in it but I'm never there cuz I
have to work and this is this is the
trauma the trauma is we failed our
younger Generations they don't
understand that work is not a bad thing
they hate work and so they want instant
gratification this is exemplified in
what these cities are the solution to
the homeless problem is building a
culture that refuses to allow and
support homelessness if a homeless
person lives is living on your streets
they they get removed by force where
they go is entirely up to them or you
can just say arrest them and detain them
but I think the the the police should
simply go up and say you are not allowed
to sleep on on the sidewalk on public
property and the arguments actually gone
the other direction but then also people
should not be giving free food to
homeless people there should be but why
not because it enables it it it it it
you you are you are basically fueling
the traumas of people so instead of
instead of helping someone get clean and
find a way to sustain themselves you are
basically saying let me keep giving you
more drugs let me let me sustain your
that's what the safe injection sites do
and now you've got now you've got tyus
and bubanic plague Bubonic plague less
so but it did emerge several times and
freak people out but tyus is all over
the place Ty because homeless people are
being given food that promotes so yeah
it's all it's all rooted in uh it all
goes down to you reduce it how is it
possible for homeless people to set up
mass encampments in these Parks people
give them free food if there's no food
they they they have to go somewhere to
get food if we made it so that food
could only be given to the homeless in
like a place 70 miles away from the
cities and then all all anyone could do
is be like we gave our contribution to
the to distribution center it's 70 mil
outside of the city and that allowed for
homeless people to to go somewhere else
to to to get resources cuz we want help
them then it keeps them out of cities
and stops the spread of disease that
that that'd be better than just saying I
see you sleeping there on the ground in
your own waist I see disease spreading
and and wild animals and mange let me
give you food so that you can keep doing
it and you can't enable bad behaviors
you have to like someone is hurting
themselves you don't say what can I do
to make sure you keep doing it we say
how can I get you to stop this improve
yourself and become self-sufficient
there's been a lot of programs that are
like trying to help people get jobs you
know remember Kimberly clck yeah um she
had this whole not for profit that was
uh designed to give women clothing that
they could then interview in it was like
professional clothing for women who
don't can't afford professional clothing
and she helped people she helped all
these women get jobs because she gave
them like the right outfits to go into a
a job interview and look presentable
there's a lot of different ways that you
can help people without facilitating a
degenerative lifestyle yeah you you
mentioned how feeding the people is
feeding the problem and Michael
shellenberger has done a lot of
reporting on the California Homeless
Problem and how these organizations
these multi-million dollar Charities are
receiving money to fund the people and
then they just keep receiving money to
keep funding the problem and the problem
never ends because if the problem ends
then the charity goes away and they lose
their job so they've kind of got a an
incentive uh structure there's like an
industry built up it's like what
happened to the Human Rights Campaign
the Human Rights Campaign was founded to
uh get gay marriage passed and then once
gay marriage got passed they switched to
trans stuff it's not just that it's a
green piece all every major nonprofit
that's looking at Mass Revenue they're
thinking to themselves look I don't want
to lose my job and I want to fire
everybody so what is the mission of this
nonprofit well if problem X has been
solved we must come up with problem y
most big major npos are operating on
some wild far from their
found I want to be intellectually honest
so I I think there's elements of Truth
in what you're saying there is an NGO
industrial complex I've seen it up close
so I get it and there is an incentive to
keep people destitute I I don't want to
deny that but fundamentally since I've
never seen an actual mass scale effort
with all the resources that we have to
really address this issue to really make
people where they are to try to address
people's underlying trauma I'm not
willing to endorse this punitive
approach where you have to make people
go far away to get food where you have
to try to lock well because you're
basically saying that you have no right
to be here if you if you want to eat you
have to go somewhere else if you want to
receive free food we've got it for you
down the street that's not at all but
but then you're also infringing on the
freedom of me if I want to give someone
food you're infringing on my freedom to
give them that food and and that's the
problem so I said there there is no
moral solution you can't ban someone
from giving someone else food but then
the problem is I would agree with you if
we if we had actually tried to address
this problem seriously and given that we
haven't yet there hasn't been again I'm
sorry to repeat myself but all the money
we put into war if we put into to this
issue and it still didn't make a
difference fine I then you I think the I
think the solution is actually
relatively simple we need better we we
need better jobs we need to uh abolish
the Department of Education we need to
get people how would that help the
Department of Education like all of
education has gone and test scores and
everything has gone directly downhill
since the founding of the Department of
Education yes I'm being personally uh uh
uh provocative but the point is that we
are not teaching people people how to
function and survive and Live Well we
are teaching them dependency that was my
point when this young woman is saying
why do I have to work to pay bills you
shouldn't have to you should want to the
problem is human beings that are being
raised in the United States over the
past few Generations are being raised in
such a way that work is some alien thing
that is painful to do whereas it should
be enjoyable a guy who likes building
tables should be like man I built three
tables today I made a really cool one
take a look at my table some people have
this passion instead you get young
people who are like I literally don't
want to do anything now I can certainly
understand not wanting to coate papers
and file TPS reports that's nuts some
people are into that the issue is that
there are many many people today who
want to do nothing so what happens is
the people who are living out in the
streets who want to do nothing are
enabled to do nothing and then create a
strain on everyone around them this is
causing people to flee cities in
California and move in Mass to like
Florida and Texas where things are very
very different this is not a sustainable
system so we need we need we need a m I
say it's it's really just you know vote
Trump there you go have a nice day
everybody we need we need to educate
young people we need to inspire young
people we need to stop promoting College
college is a waste of people's time it's
not helping anybody become functioning
members of society a a liberal arts
degree is not something that can help
build or create or maintain life and so
you got a lot of these young people who
are like I know everything about
folklore and mythology but but I'll be
I'll be damned if I could fix a you know
change a card Tire I'm one of those
people so I get what you're saying I I
do and um but again I think it's comes
down to you know how you view Humanity I
think your experience with people and I
understand that you have a direct
experience with this so I respect that
has left you with a more cynical view of
how people operate most young people I
know they want to have they want to do
well they want to have meaningful work
but there's no opportunity for it
anymore the other thing too means you're
doing something that you know you feel
is an expression of yourself that's
contributing to the world that you find
meaningful how do we how do we develop
uh that passion well I mean I that's a
question of circumstance too like how
you're able to grow up how privileged
you are I mean I mean all that stuff and
it's an issue of privilege privileged
people don't like working and so when
they grow up these are these are the
younger Generations are some of the most
privileged people the Earth has ever
seen and so when you take someone who 0
to 5 years old what are they doing
sitting in front of a tablet 5 to 13
they're going to school but it's mostly
non work where they're getting
participation trophies then they go to
high school nothing changes then they go
to college the entire experience is just
do what you're told and will provide for
you they graduate and they're like I
don't want to do anything whereas what
it used to be is so uh for me I grew up
homeschooled as soon as like super early
ages preschool I'm I'm I'm doing
education I worked at the family
business when I was 9 till like 11 years
old took the train in the bus by myself
as a little kid working a job making
money and buying the things that I
wanted I had the internet ever since I
was a kid so I'm reading things on
online all day every day and just
learning stuff and and it's more and
more interesting every day Wikipedia was
a game changer and then I started just
doing things I wanted to do got good at
them and then all of a sudden what
happens when I'm 18 I am better than all
of my peers at basic skills I have
already had two or three different jobs
so I I know how to apply I know how to
make a resume they're struggling with
these things they don't want to get jobs
they're they're going to school oh I'm
gonna go to college instead they
graduate from college they can't find
any meaningful work why they have no
experience okay and that's an issue I
you know that's why I'm saying
Department of Education gone strip away
this education industrial complex the
other thing to about meaning rather
rather than abolish the Department of
Education why not actually invest more
in the education system so it's not
working we're we're throwing good money
after bad well but the problem we've
also under It With Charter Schools and
actually underfunding the education
system I I know people I know everyone I
know in the education system are
hardworking people who are trying to do
the best you know why there's two words
that break down any argument you might
have and you know that is school sucks
school does say and every kid says it
and they've said it for 50 years and
we've never stopped to ask why kids keep
saying school sucks and then what
happens is you get older people being
like well it's because respons nah not
sorry not true every video of every kid
super excited by the science teacher
who's making a rocket chip out of a
balloon or something or doing the thing
with the big water barrel the the water
jug and then they light it in the fire
goes Doof shoots out and they're super
excited having a blast the problem is
those people are so incredibly rare
school sucks and the answer of let's
give more money to what sucks makes
literally no sense kids from my gen from
when I was a kid to previous generations
have been screaming the machine is
broken and we just tell them too bad
well plenty of kids also would hate
eating their vegetables but that doesn't
mean they shouldn't eat their vegetables
wrong you get Gordon Ramsey to make
broccoli and spinach and brussel sprouts
for kid got season that man wow
okay so there you go so
the so when you have a bad Chef you
don't give him a raise you fire him and
then try and find a better most teachers
that I know are wonderful people who are
doing their best they don't have the
support they need their their classes
are overcrowded needs kids don't have
the support they need that's not the is
education's ever been seriously funny
because we're too busy funding for
special needs kids like I'm
seeing I agree the Foreign Wars things
is bad but like that's it's that's
that's not a one for one we should
certainly take whatever funding from all
the foreign war garbage and put it into
our own infrastructure I big part of the
issue is the curriculum is trash the way
it's being taught is bad the teachers no
matter how hard you say that they're
working like I literally watched them
every day for a year and a half when my
son was home with you know because of
coid and whatever and they were teaching
him they were doing like lessons about
white supremacy and systemic racism
instead of teaching him math they were
doing all of this stuff they like for a
recent science project he had the point
of of the science project was to write a
biography of a scientist who was not a
white male and my kid was telling me
about this this class and I was like
this is don't do this assignment let's
just simplify it Ain can you explain to
me
photosynthesis uh at this point no I
couldn't I why why did you even bother
learning it well because at a certain
point it's important to grasp these
basic concepts and in my in my
particular case I don't have a very
scientific mind so I'm not a good
example somebody who was somebody who
paid attention of to science class I I
feel bad for all the for for all the
kids who weren't as lucky as I I am that
I had entrepreneurs in my family who
taught me basic work function and like
business management and stuff so you are
lucky that's great but not everyone has
has that I know and so my my my thing is
like man how can we stop the corrupt
system that is that is hurting these
people and give them something better
that can make them happy and passionate
and successful why not give them the
same support that you had in your family
to be able to learn so here's what
you're going need to do you're going to
need to have your family lose their
house they're going to have to risk
everything on a small business that
fails and those life lessons will help
them learn the value of hard work and
make them passionate about improving and
succeeding but if you give them more
money for things that are broken I think
you'll get the opposite outcome or you
look at your case and you say wow how
amazing is it that this family went
through all this and still struggled and
made it and was able to produce someone
like yourself who has knowledge who is
uh self-sufficient
and saying that's a wonderful thing
let's make sure everyone has the basic
opportunities so that if things go bad
that they're self-sufficient too and
they have knowledge rather than
underfunding their schools and denying
are not educating kids well they could I
mean I agree with you a serious problem
and co co was a and this is the problem
this this is the problem I see with the
left our nation has this how I always
describe it everyone's going to say oh
here Co them again this country has a
wound on its arm the wound started
bleeding and that is our kids need to be
educated this is a problem so what did
we do we put a bandage on it and said
that'll help solve the problem and you
know what a bandage on a wound is a
really good idea and then 3 weeks later
we looked down at it and it was covered
in dirt and grime and it was festering
and someone said I don't think that's
helping anymore I got an idea let's put
another bandage on it so we slapped
another bandage on it I get the metaphor
I got it you got you got necrosis baby
you got you got necrotizing fasciitis in
the education system and that's why I'm
saying stop it start something else we
need a dramatic re overhaul of of look
man if Bart Simpson has been saying
since the late 80s school sucks and it
was a laughable idea that everyone
agreed with the system was broken we've
all known it's been broken and instead
of saying hey maybe we should stop the
thing that sucks that everyone hates and
try and reassess this and create
something different the answer just
seems to be every single step of the way
from the left is just give more money I
don't have the Fidelity in children's uh
opinions of school that like you do
because come on you know school sucks
looking back I can think of plenty of
times when I thought school sucked but
looking back on it I benefit a lot from
having an education and you don't have
but but are you talking about college
cuz school is not education both both
elementary school high school and
college I really benefited from even if
at times I didn't enjoy it I mean kids
don't enjoy things when they're
difficult and they're boring and the
isue benefit from it the presumption
that what you experienced in schools was
beneficial versus the alternative of not
being in school there's no control for
that in fact there could be technically
it's me I'm a high school dropout yeah
so when people keep saying to me yeah
but you're lucky you're the exception
I'm like I'm the exception that I
stopped going to these state funded
institutionalized learning facilities
that jam your head in a box and take
away your ability to survive that
obviously worked really well for you I
just don't think from that you
extrapolate that that's a solution for
everybody yeah I'm not saying my
solution is a solution for everybody I'm
saying the mechanization and
industrialization of of what we would
call learning has failed it's not people
aren't learning properly it's school it
might be education but we're going to
try get some super
we got to get super I've always enjoyed
learning but I like Interactive Learning
I think the best way to do it is
oneon-one if you have your teacher and
your student maybe your parent and the
kid but I mean it's a big ask for
society to start schooling their kids no
no I got Solutions let's talk about this
more on the members only so I can at
least read some super chats Clint Torres
of course is number one saying hotti
people and also don't forget to smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends go to
Tim cast.com click join us the
uncensored show will be up in like 13
minutes or so but we're having a good
conversation so all right Alpa tury says
representation matters the MCU proves
that diverse woman can direct a flop
just as poorly as a white man there you
go yeah uh the Marvels is the biggest
Marvel failure yeah like all time like
officially right it's the lowest box you
call it a failure it's I'm being mean
it's the lowest box office opening of
any Marvel movie at $47 million and we
all know exactly why sorry they made
they made a it's
like the movie is quite literally a
poster for diversity I'm I'm starting to
fall asleep just listening to the benon
ad or something it's like the beniton
Marvel movie a white woman a black woman
and a middle eastern woman teaming up to
fight a black woman and it's like is
there a bald guy in it there is is he
the villain no he he's Sam Samuel
Jackson he helps there's no bald villain
I meant bald white guys what I I
literally don't care about diverse casts
in the literal sense it's when they
hamfist these stories with wokeness and
like girl power stuff where it's just
like stop stop please you're patronizing
us but let's uh let's read some more
Shane H Wilder says if Clint doesn't say
howdy people did the show even happen it
did not we actually leave we just we
like it's guys it's 7:45 and Clint's not
here we just is that Clint Torres
offline just we got to go we gotta go
there yeah see at first it was Raymond g
Stanley Jr we were he had to he had to
Super Chat and if he didn't we were
concerned you know but now he's here all
the time so it's just like shout out to
ra Master G yeah that guy rocking it
brown bear 992 says flamethrower clown
2024 uh on MSNBC they said Trump is a
clown with a flame flamethrower and a
clown with a flamethrower still has a
flamethrower or something like that so
you know oh hey we should make that Shir
really cool yeah I hope someone's
listening can we make that shirt it
should be like Bozo Bozo the Clown
remember clown like ah and then out of
the Flames coming Trump's face and he's
going ah like making the same face as
the clown you can tell the clown is
Donald Trump or it could be Trump with
clown makeup you blow torching like oh
it could be that you know like a corrupt
corrupt symbol of Corruption of some
sort swamp yeah he's burning a swamp
down don't just drain it and he's
wearing a Laticia James t-shirt yeah
that could be it that could be it wow
man YouTube uh got rid of a bunch of
super chats that's that's super annoying
yeah man the FCB 5 says I'm center right
but I stand with the left on
Israel well all
right Common Sense fishing says I know
my history was originally uh occupied by
Jews Arabs came out of Arabia and
conquered it around 600 BC even though
Jews lived there it was technically
ruled by Arabs for 1500 years until 1948
yeah but before that it was the
Canaanites Abraham died over there in
Canaan and then his great-grandson was
Judah and the kingdom of Judah followed
that so way before the kingdom of Judea
was
Canaan there's a there's a song that was
really popular a while ago it's called
This Land Is My Land you ever see it oh
yeah and it just shows all the different
groups that go back and forth over over
claiming the land kind of crazy I don't
think it's overtly critical of any group
it's just showing the history of the
region and all the different groups who
had waged war on it it's kind of crazy
it's like uh humanity is the is the game
of land acquisition over centuries the
story of humanity is taking land from
other people and and energy consumption
yeah these are the two things finding
better ways to to extract energy from
various system man if we could just
build land if Humanity just siphoned off
volcanic molten lava into the ocean to
make new islands and stuff or well look
out Iceland right
from under volano issues in Iceland oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah redirected to the
coasts right maybe maybe we could out uh
uh we could buy a bunch of land in
Iceland and and give it to the
Palestinians and you know what that's
not a bad idea right like everyone just
move around nor Pacific garbage gy and
just like pour concrete on it and make
that make that an island if you so have
you ever watched videos of it the North
Pacific garbage sh yeah it's not dense
no it's not I'm joking around here so
people people think it's a they call it
a garbage island but it's like well
there's a lot of garbage floa it's a
like but it's like when you're floating
in it you just see Speckles of garbage
it still looks like the ocean you know
but people are people are imagining it's
this like thick dense spattering of
garbage it's not really what about
Albatross Island isn't there like an
Island covered yeah that's what it is
pit Karen pit Karen there's like 58
people live in there yeah and it's like
covered with trash you can make an
island out of trash Richard SOA uh you
can make structures out of out of trash
we've solved the Israel Palestine
conflict and the homel problem because
you can build houses out of trash we are
going to create a series of of
islands and you know who's really good
at that is Dubai the Dubai is good at
that why isn't Dubai just doing that
they're okay at it a lot of their
islands are kind of going by by now oh
really that big like palm tree island
like the world and stuff it it collapsed
it's in the process of doing so the
ocean is saying I want this stuff back
actually we'd like our we'd like our
place back I want to geise our magma
straight up from the bottom of the ocean
in certain places and just make these
islands isn't Hawaii doesn't Hawaii have
that potenti that's how all Islands form
actually but CP ideas guys they're going
to start making Islands in much place we
don't they don't necessarily like yeah
let's we'll read some more Paul tascal
says as the left aligns with Palestine
haven't heard a peep about Sharia law
awful culture of domestic violence 20%
of marriages are an adult male to a
female child bride homosexuality is
illegal strange Ally for progressives
this is Palestine they said yeah yeah
it's it's illegal to be gay it's 10
years in prison keep in mind some of
those domestic violence things like if
they live under oppression that can
cause the disruption of the family too
like if you're stressed and you go home
to your wife you know that can affect
your
relationship you know there isn't
actually Sharia law imposed in Gaza but
regardless no matter what you think
about that there is not you said it's
not sha is not official inside Hamas has
floated it I'm sure they'd want to but
it's but
regardless no matter what you think
about all that they don't have the right
to Israel doesn't have the right to
occupy them and besiege them and kill
them and deny them food and medicine
that's my fundamental Point uh how the
people of Palestine uh in the
territories govern themselves that's up
to them but what I don't want to do is
support anything that can be used to
oppress them and displace them I think
that's I don't care I don't want to
provide funding for that's fine if we
get to if we get to the same conclusion
I don't care how you got there morally
though if you if we were talking about
Native Americans and we were you know
like doing all this today I'd be like we
should stop doing this stuff okay if if
if we were talking about you know
millions of Native Americans on a small
land I'd be like guys we got to we got
to have a solution to this is not
working it's going to get worse however
the Israel Palestine thing is I'm just
like I am
just look I I care about the moral
morality of humanity and the death and
all that stuff but I'm saying
politically we don't even need to argue
about the morality of the region because
I think America shouldn't be spending
money on all these foreign countries I
think I would rather take all of the
money spent on all of these foreign
countries put it in a big plastic ball
roll it up to a random guy named Rick's
house and just give it to him and be
like I you're a trillionaire now for
some reason literally don't care you are
the king and have fun with the money
because it's better spent on you than
anyone else look an american guy or
woman in this country with all of that
money is infinitely better to me than
whatever garbled nonsense we're doing I
would push back in that I would would
have pushed back because the conquest of
Iraq Afghanistan Syria uh Lebanon um
where else have we taken Libya we
haven't really taken Syria Libya we kind
of have taken Syria Libya Egypt we have
puppet state Israel puppet state it's
because we needed oil but now I'm like
well we can create hydrogen fuel with
this byproduct of graphine and we can
turn the oil into graphine so we don't
need to shut it down we don't need the
oil we just need other people not to
have it the point is to control whether
or not they can grow and what they can
do so correct Maybe we can let go I
don't know if that's even yeah I'm like
I love the idea of secure our borders
bring bring our jobs in manufacturing
back restore a a solid American culture
with good moral foundations like that
means life liberty Pursuit of Happiness
that means individual liberties
meritocracy it means we don't keep work
like these people who are like why do I
have to work and pay taxes just so I can
struggle I'm like well I don't agree
with the work thing but at least I can
say this to these young people I
completely agree the fact that we're
paying taxes which goes into garbage
look man fix the roads you know what I
mean let's just like just we'll build a
bunch of roads I don't care where they
go just anything is better than us being
like why are we spending two decades
nation building in Afghanistan yeah
improving roads is key in 2021 the US
gave foreign countries 52.4 billion
dollar and since that's it got be more
than that it's what it says the most
that's this is from this is 2021 here's
what we're going to do 52.4 billion we
are going since then we gave 113 billion
to ukra
wow okay so here's what we do and Joe
Biden wants another $60 billion because
he needs that war to continue till his
reelection campaign in 2021 it was 3.3
billion to Israel 1.6 to Jordan 1.4 to
Afghanistan okay okay I propose this I
mean it's kind of
crazy I propose this to all of America
tonight that 200 plus billion
dollar that all of the all of the fut so
it's already been spent I get it
so from this point forward until forever
anytime a bill is passed or some kind of
plan or whatever to give money to a
foreign country no matter what they
think will happen the bank account gets
all redirected to Ian okay then we're
going to use half a billion of it to
create closed system nuclear recycling
systems to you could buy a historic
collection of playboys for all I care
you get the money no more warmers my
uncle Sid would love that he had a
historic collection of playboys and he
kept them he kept them in in the like
front room the little front room just in
a little stack between two chairs both
of which were you know covered with
plastic cuz that's what my aunt Dory did
you couldn't sit on anything let let me
try and read some more here I try and
get can Captain John says Tim's 100%
correct I have a homeless father and
brother both drug addicts they are out
there by choice I gave my brother a home
and a job and he chose to go back out
there yeah I knew a dude who uh made he
he would make like 250 bucks a day yeah
he would put a folder SC in front of him
and then go to sleep on uh on uh State
Street in Chicago and then he said I
just go to sleep during the day wake up
it's full he walked into the bank and he
poured it into the change machine and
then they added it to his account then
he would then he would go and like 250
bucks a day not bad like but he was a
drug addict right and so I was like man
you're making bank dude I wish I made
that much money what do you do with and
he goes a I I do heroin man and I was
like oh well that's really bad like 250
bucks a day you'd be living like a king
and he's just yeah
I'm like and that and that's why he was
messed up and was I've had similar
experiences trying to help people that
don't want to help themselves is not
possible no it's not it's exhausting
Baron of Grey says we spend so much
money on the homeless in Washington
state that you could give each homeless
person
$150,000 is that what he says
$150,000 it's the homeless industrial
complex it's big business so much money
in it it will never be fixed I agree yep
same with LA man you know I learned one
of these shelters my favorite thing I
learned was that they would pitch that
they were their shelters were at
capacity and so they were in desperate
need of donation so they could expand
and the reality was all the shelters
were empty because the homeless people
did not want to be in them and so I'm
like I didn't know that and when I found
it out I said I I can't I can't lie to
people like this and they're like but
you need the urgency and I'm like I'll
just not mention it what I can't work
for these companies man that's why I
didn't want to work in the industry
anymore they all lie nonprofits all of
them the only ones that are good are the
small ones where it's like we're here to
rescue puppies and then they do and
you're like oh that's great and it's
like two people in a house and they also
live in the house and they take care of
puppies yep I like those places too I
like puppies yeah
man all right let's see poly puree says
the original Coca-Cola had cocaine in it
cream soda had hero in it back in around
120 years ago whoa and uh when they made
cocaine illegal Coca-Cola was like let's
do caffeine why because caffeine is
extremely psychoactiv similar to cocaine
oh wow that's good I've discovered that
myself look up look up the physiological
uh um reactions between cocaine and
caffeine you'll be like that sounds very
similar wow it is indeed it's very much
indeed similar but we just don't snort
caffeine or anything like that we just
eat little bits that would weird right
if somebody was like snorting caffeine
you'd be like what is that I've never
taken caffeine pills I knew people that
would do that that sound like you could
overdose Jo Joseph metler says the US
spends more on education than on
defense why and that's wild because
people aren't learning properly Damar
says Baltimore $21,000 per student spent
money is not the solution never was
that's true in New York too like the the
huge amount of money that's spent per
kid um and it's a disas like the
education is not doing anything good for
anyone should be fun man learning is so
funar School beats it out of Y I hate
sitting still it's like Let's Talk About
It smash the like button subscribe to
the channel share the show with your
friends and head over to timcast.net
join us and we are going to rag on
school although Aaron May disagree but
it'll be a good conversation so become a
member that's going to come up in a few
minutes you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Aaron do you want to shout
anything out uh the gry zone.com I also
co-host a podcast called useful idiots
that's at useful idiots podcast.com I do
that with my friend Katie Halper I'm
also on substack uh mate. substack
docomond and as usual I always want to
shout out the post-millennial the post
millennial.age and we'd love if you
would subscribe to the post millennial
at the post
millennial.age is war you know uh Middle
Eastern war and conflict especially in
Ukraine but on the after you mentioned
something on the show about when does
defense of your nation go too far like
how how much of a an attack can you do
and then still call it a defensive
maneuver the Romans you know notoriously
conquered their neighbors at of Defense
of Capital so I'd love to talk more
about that we'll get into it and uh also
follow my my uh videos on YouTube
subscribe to my channel Ian cross and
check out Friday Jimmy corsetti we went
hard on Atlantis and then I talked to
Michael Lane building a space elevator
on the moon on Saturday and that's going
to happen so check it out see you there
and I am surge.com
um I have nothing to say I hope you guys
have a good day and let's go to the
after show we'll see you all over at
timcast.net